has to an extent funneled people towards
the beaches of Cali hasn't it indeed and
I think MPS like like Damian green and
others in Kent have been very concerned
about the fact that they their
constituencies have had the brunt of
people stay in hotels while their cases
are decided but every so often something
happens like this and like it did last
November was just put into perspective
how dangerous these Journeys are and
what can happen to the people who put
their their lives in the hands of these
these people Smugglers
um in in really very cold conditions and
you know every so often I think she
brings MPS up short to remember that
these tragedies can happen
indeed
um and I suspect there will be a degree
of reflection on on what has been
happening and just given the the numbers
that are involved
but but this is this is a live issue and
it is a live issue not just for the
people who who stay in and around that
that part of the world politically as an
issue that this has been something that
people have been have been suggesting it
it is something that weighs on their
mind now that is not to say that people
are opposed to immigration per se that
people are opposed to people applying
for asylum in this country but it does
sometimes feel that this has been a part
of our national conversation that we've
sometimes just skipped over a little bit
because it because it involves some some
pretty difficult decisions being made by
our senior politicians and vicious
Scenic as if anything made this such a
key priority set a very high price on
succeeding I mean he said that he wanted
to get the backlog of 150 people in the
Asylum system got through by the end of
next year which is uh you would think
quite close to the general election that
has set himself a very high bar he talks
a lot about stopping the small boats we
heard that from pretty Patel for many
years that she was going to stop the
small boats and she really did try with
a number of different tactics but it was
very difficult to make them work and to
certainly make to make them work legally
so many politicians have tried to tackle
this especially since the numbers have
gone up so much certainly in the last
couple of years taking that particular
route I mean that people did used to
take different routes but this is a
particularly visible route but whether
Rishi sinaka set himself this huge
challenge of cracking down on small
boats which we've heard from MPS
particularly in sort of um what's called
the red wall areas say that this is a
huge issue for voters and that they'll
lose the election if he doesn't succeed
he's he's really set himself this task
and it will take many months and
legislation through both houses of
Parliament to get any real changes there
I would just the latest in terms of the
rescue operation that is taking place in
the channel from the French site of the
channel I should say they're reporting
that the Customs Coast Guard Patrol
would uh carmorvan is to be made
available to the Dover Coast Guard to to
reinforce the resources already deployed
in the area but this statement from the
amount of time in Coast Guard agency
just gives you an idea of of the
coordinated efforts that are all going
on in the channel this morning uh his
Majesty's Coast Guard is currently
coordinating his search and rescue
response to an instant involving a small
boat off Kent working with the Navy
border Force Kent Police and other
partners
it's not just the military and and those
who who work in the public sector
um clearly as this statement shows a
fishing vessel in the area uh the
maritime Coast Guard agency say is also
assisting in the rescue southeast coast
ambulance and Kent Police are working
with us and an air ambulance has been
sent this incident is ongoing and we
have no further information we do have
however via Lisa Holland uh just the
detail that we we do understand that
there have been fatalities in all of
this which is possibly why soella
bravaman has has said this on Twitter
just a few minutes ago I'm aware she
says of a distressing incident in the
channel this morning and I'm being kept
constantly updated while agencies
respond and urgently establish the full
facts my heartfelt thoughts are with all
of those involved
uh statement from the unhcr they say
they are gravely concerned at reports
of a of an incident involving a small
boat carrying an estimated 30 people in
the channel early this morning and we
are seeking further information from the
UK authorities at that stage the U.N
High Commissioner for refugees
our details are still emerging and we
have no real specific figures yet but
Sky News understands the number of
people on the small boat was between 30
and 50. if we take a quick look at the
map this will show you exactly where we
believe it to be unfolding
um well we'll show you in a second
around halfway basically between the
Kent coast and the coast of France in
terms of the rescue effort itself we
understand that to Search and Rescue
helicopters cross a french navy
helicopter rnli lifeboats and a number
of other UK and French Navy boats are
involved in the rescue searches to
continue all day but at this stage at
those searching or not looking for the
living
given the temperature of the water
um just before we move on there also
worth saying that you know information
that we have from the rnli suggests that
those lifeboats were launched
shortly after three o'clock this morning
uh let's bring in if we can the director
general of the Border force uh 20 sorry
the former director General I should say
of the UK border force uh Tony Smith and
Tony I really appreciate you coming on
for us this morning just just if you can
just tell us what will be going on in
terms of coordination to try and and do
as much as they can we understand that
this is not a search and rescue
operation at the moment though
well absolutely you know I think people
need to understand first and foremost
that the top priority not just for the
Border Falls but for all of the
associated agencies will be to save
lives at Sea
um that's what we've been doing for a
long time now there will have been a
number of of exercises already they will
know exactly what to do there will be a
command structure in place and you know
our authorities our agencies will be
doing everything they possibly can to
save to save lives and to bring people
ashore as you say we don't know yet uh
the details of this incident those will
no doubt emerge over time but rest
assured that will be the top priority of
our officers out there right now uh will
be to try and make people safe and well
that is our first and foremost
consideration absolutely Tony but in
terms when you when you see when you
talk about uh operations joint
operations will have been carried out I
mean ultimately people will have planned
and prepared for exactly this type of
event eventuality
oh absolutely yes and I mean it's not
the first time it's happened of course I
mean you mentioned earlier on you know
the fact that last November sadly we
lost lives you know there was a report
written about that that's available
harrowing stories of people from
far-flung places trying to track down
whether or not they had relatives on
that boat you know a significant number
of irregular migrants in the EU trying
to get across it's a very very difficult
scenario but in terms of the operational
response we are now I think well
equipped and we have saved I think an
awful lot of lives I think we can only
you know count our blessings that we
haven't seen more incidents like this
but we really do need to hammer home the
message I think through media not to do
this not to pay Smugglers to get into a
boat it's very tempting when you can see
the Cliffs of Dover from the beaches of
Calais sometimes and it looks very
simple but these are dangerous waterways
and in these conditions freezing Waters
dark small dinghies that are not fit for
purpose we've really got to to
discourage people and from trying this
and not falling into the hands of of
human Smugglers who really don't care
about human life I've dealt with them in
my career they're not interested in that
they're only interested in the money
and Tony then speak to me about this
particular aspect of the story just just
I'm sitting here with the wire Services
open in front of me and detail is coming
in through all the time so apologies
I've feels like they sound slightly
disjointed but we're told that the rnla
lifeboats were launched shortly after
three o'clock this morning which
suggests of course that the incident
itself took place you know just a short
a short while before people are
traveling across the channel at that
type people are crossing the channel at
that particular time in the morning
presumably to try and avoid detection
but at that time in the morning dear God
only knows what the temperature is like
both in the air as much as in the water
what exactly as you know we have been
working with the French there was a new
agreement quite recently actually that
we would Place border Force officers in
France working in on operations on the
Calais beaches you know you've you've
had footage of what that environment is
like uh they don't want to be detected
on the beaches because if they are they
will be the the vessels will be disabled
they'll be stopped from Crossing so
there's a game of cat and mouse going on
along a very long stretch of French
Beach there between law enforcement and
the Smugglers and so they will uh you
know resort to Desperate Measures as you
say this will have been dark it will
have been cold the people would have
been frightened but they would have been
assured by the pilot or by somebody
behind this look this is easy don't
worry about this it's not very far just
getting here and everything's going to
be okay and that's what happens so
that's why the messaging is so important
to people that if we can get the message
out please do not do not engage with
human smuggles to get across the English
Channel we have to stop this we have to
stop the boats because I'm afraid This
is highly highly dangerous as you say
you can just imagine what it must be
like for some of those people that are
in that boat in the dark in those
freezing temperatures when our vessel
runs into trouble on the English Channel
we cannot guarantee your safety we can
only do everything in our power to try
and save lives but we cannot guarantee
that because these are really really
difficult conditions and these are
Dangerous Waters and I'm afraid that
message is not played up enough in this
whole debate no entirely totally but but
you yourself will know from working out
border force that the people will
continue will continue to go to Cali to
seek out these people Smugglers and try
and get across the channel if there are
no other ways for them to make it to the
United Kingdom I mean that's just a
simple statement of fact isn't it
well yeah so I mean I was interested I
mean there's been a lot of debate about
safe and legal routes um I was
interested to hear the Prime Minister
say that they are looking at that they
want to work with the unhcr there is a
global problem here uh that you know
there's about 120 million people I think
last I saw from unhcr who are already
displaced around the world you know many
of them are in camps many of the
vulnerable people I think there is an
obligation upon the uh on the Western
World to take many many more of them
that needs a fundamental review it's a
bit like climate change it's a massive
Global issue it's really important
though that we don't conflate two
different issues here there is a big
challenge about legal it's not just into
the UK but I think you know right across
uh where we're seeing irregular
migration right across the world that is
a huge issue but I'm afraid safe and
legal putting a processing sensor in
Cali is not going to fix this I'm afraid
because that will just attract more and
more people into northern France I'm
afraid disappointed applicants will
probably still take to the boats anyway
the Smugglers will still be operating in
that region that is not the solution of
course we need to look at all options
about how we can help with the global
migration crisis but I think between two
safe third countries both signatures to
the 1951 conventions on human rights and
refugees both friendly countries law
enforcement agencies working shoulder to
shoulder together we really ought to be
able to come to a political
accommodation between us which would
stop these boats and I think that's what
the aspiration is so far that's been a
step too far
um Tony what is your appraisal of the
level of effort that is being put in on
the French side of the channel to stop
this happening
well I can only really speak an
operational level I'm not a politician
you need to get you know you get money
ministers and French ministers on here
to talk to you about that but I've you
know we we did it we've done a lot of
work over the years we've got a lot of
bilateral agreements with the French I
know I've met them myself during my
career they don't like smuggers anymore
than we do uh they don't like fraud they
don't like criminality they want to work
with us uh on on border security there
is no doubt in my mind about this this
political issue and of course you've got
to look at the you know if you look
through the lens of the French
government the EU government they've got
huge problems their own on Asylum
Seekers they're getting 60 or 70
increases at the external EU Frontier
I'm glad we're talking to the Calais
group about this now I'm glad that our
ministers are speaking at senior levels
about this about how we actually manage
migrants across the EU and Beyond
because it's a massive problem so I I
don't think that at operational level
there is any hesitancy at all between us
and the French police working together
but we only all have our own respective
Powers authorities and mandates there's
only so much we're able to do under the
under the mandates that we're given so
it really does demand an increased
effort and an ongoing effort of dialogue
between ourselves and the EU I've
advocated joint patrols before there's
things we can do onto an international
law in the contiguous there's all kinds
of things that we could do with
International agreement with the EU that
we haven't done which would simply say
look you can't come across by this route
and if you do you'll just go straight
back to France but you can understand
from their point of view they've got
very large numbers of migrants coming up
through the Schengen Zone themselves and
actually you know that this is a shared
problem not a not a not a French problem
so it is hugely complicated a political
level but it's so sad that it takes
events like this to bring this message
home about what a dangerous business
this is what an awful business this is I
really hope we can uh you know come at
some point so in a come accommodation
which actually stops this altogether
um Tony many thanks to your time this
morning I really really do appreciate it
and as we Edge towards as we age towards
10 o'clock Amanda Cass with one of our
political correspondents here at
Westminster has been speaking to a
source who confirms that there have been
definite fatalities in the channel a
migrant bought with over 40 people on
board have capsized the search will
continue all day but given the water
temperature she is told at further
rescues are unlikely it is at 10 o'clock
and we're reporting on that breaking
news emerging at from the channel uh a
major incident has been declared there
the Royal Navy uh the French navy coast
guards lifeboats uh certain search
helicopters all involved a huge
operation scan news however understands
that people have indeed lost their life
after a boat carrying more than 40
people is thought to have capsized
now let's try and bring you up to date
with the latest details are still
emerging certainly no word on any
specific numbers yet but Sky News
understands the number of people on the
small boat was between 30 and 50.
searches will continue all day but at
this stage not looking for the living we
are not looking for the living given the
temperature of the water now this is the
point in the channel where we understand
that events have been unfolding around
about halfway between the French coast
and the Kent Coast there are a minimum
of two Search and Rescue helicopters
perhaps you've indeed a French nearly
helicopter has been added to that rnli
lifeboats other UK and French Navy boats
are involved in that rescue and let's
bring in Skies Lisa Holland who's been
on top of this story for us and Lisa
just just as much information as you can
give us about about what has been
happening details coming through in
spits and spats at the moment
yes I mean to be honest in the words of
of one uh Source down on the south coast
that I spoke to this morning
um he said to me it's a big boat uh so
we and we have subsequently discovered
that we understand that there could be
around about 40 people on board I mean
just to give you a sense
um that people who were crossing the
channel last night trying to get from
France to Kent
um although conditions are said to be
calm on the channel of course it would
have been perilously cold
um and I I understand that really the
guesstimate is that the actual air
temperature would have felt like about
minus four which would probably put a uh
the kind of survival rate if you're in
the water about 15 to 20 minutes and
that's if you have clothes on
um and even if you had some kind of life
jacket now um the suggestion is that
this boat capsized and that there were
people in the water we haven't had
precise details confirmed yet but this
is this is um something that I've been
told
and that it happened in about 45 miles
off Dungeness Point
um there were lifeboats which were sent
from Dover Dungeness Ramsgate Hastings
also Navy border Force vessels
there appears to have been some kind of
transfer
um to the William Harvey Hospital in
Ashford in Kent now whether that is is
survivors who are picked up or or people
for whom it was simply too late is
unclear at the moment
um but uh clearly anybody crossing the
channel last night the odds would have
been very much against them if a vessel
got into water really quite a distance
from either the the English Coast dying
or the French Coastline the worst
possible scenario but you know these
vessels have continued and even the
winter months
um and the sheer cold is not deterring
people
they don't know it it certainly isn't
but I suppose the point to be made on
that Lisa is it hasn't been deterring
people for an awfully long time this is
not our first winter seeing people lose
their lives in the channel
no it's not and and you know actually
yesterday I went to meet an Albanian man
who I've been in touch with
um I went down to see him in the south
of England to talk about the
government's announcements yesterday to
try to
um deter albanians from crossing the
channel we know that the number of
albanians crossing the channel have
massively increased this year and
talking to him
um obviously this hasn't happened then
but talking to him about political
deterrence let alone something like this
um he he said to me look people will
still keep coming people never think
that this kind of thing is going to
happen to them and when thousands do
successfully make it across the channel
obviously they they don't think that
they're going to be the ones who are
going to lose their lives and they talk
about what a dangerous Journey it is
they know that and they talk about what
a frightening experience it is as well
to be in the hands of people's Smugglers
and told to meet at whatever point to
get on a boat and then sometimes in
Houston they they look and they see
boats that are absolutely bulging with
migrants trying to come across the
channel they know it's a risky business
but the end game for them to reach the
UK
um in their minds is worth it and and
this will absolutely send shock waves
amongst the the Asylum Seeker Community
the migrant Community
um but but I just don't think it will it
will stop people from coming in fact
after the incident uh when around 30
people lost their lives last November I
remember being in touch with an asylum
Seeker who was actually at a hotel in
Liverpool and uh it's deja vu really
because at that time a year ago he was
saying to me look people are really
really shocked but it's not going to
stop people coming and it didn't and it
happened
um but yeah no question it's also going
to open up at once more this very big
debate amongst the silent seeking
community that if people are to be
deterred from making this kind of
Journey it's not just the Smugglers of
course that that's the [ __ ] Network
which the government's pledged to to
crack that needs to be examined it's
also the alternative for people because
there are not frankly that many safe and
legal routes and until that changes I
don't think that you're going to stop
people from trying to make this Crossing
um Lisa we will back to you if you hear
any more but uh for no thanks very much
indeed I just want to take viewers uh
through some of the uh detail of what is
happening right now in terms of the
coordination here's a statement from I
think it is the uh the maritime agency
um yeah the maritime Coast Guard agency
hm course guard his emergency course
guard is currently coordinating a search
and rescue response to an incident
involving a small boat off Kent working
with the Navy border Force Kent Police
and other partners
fishing vessel in the area is also
resisting in the rescue Southeast Coast
Ambulance Kent Police are working with
us and an air ambulance has been sent
the incident is ongoing and we have no
further information that statement in
fact released a significant time ago now
as we understand it from our sources uh
this is not a search and rescue
operation any longer um we have however
been hearing from the Home Secretary of
course Zoella Braverman and this is what
she is saying perhaps aware of of those
reports or fatalities I am aware of a
distressing incident in the channel this
morning and I'm being kept constantly
updated while agencies respond and
urgently establish the full facts my
heartfelt thoughts are with all those
involved
her opposite number the shadow Home
Secretary Yvette Cooper said this
awful distressing reports from the
channel this morning thinking of all
those involved thank you to the agency
and rescue service teams who are
responsing responding to this immensely
difficult situation
uh let's speak now to amnesty
International's Refugee and migrant
rights program director as Steve Valdez
I mean Steve good to see you this
morning and look I will confess that I'm
getting pretty sick of having to report
on this particular story this has
happened a number of times it is not me
taking a political position to say you
know that people should not be dying in
numbers in the channel in your mind what
is responsible for the incredible
numbers that have been making this
journey this year and you know and those
losing their lives as well
well we we all have to
um
remember that the number of people who
come to our country the UK seeking
Asylum remains relatively few compared
to elsewhere
those who do often have family and
connections here
all have been unable to get safely into
an asylum system elsewhere and if you
look at the situation of people in
northern France it is not hard to
understand why people who are facing a
thoroughly miserable
Dreadful winter
homeless often having their tents ripped
apart and removed by the French police
bullied menaced want to make a journey
in the hope that this will finally bring
them to safety
unless the governments of France and the
UK will take responsibility to ensure
everybody can get safely into a system
to determine who is entitled to stay and
who is not including on this side of the
Channel with this country taking
responsibility
I'm afraid Smugglers will continue to
govern all of this and we will continue
seeing these Dreadful tragedies and
people losing their lives
I'm afraid I think you have a point
there and I I suspect though that the
the issue for for for many people
um is they cannot get to the United
Kingdom by any other means than than
crossing the channel it is fine if
you're a Ukrainian can get out of the
country if you're from from Hong Kong
but you know even Afghans who you know
would qualify for asylum in this country
are finding it difficult to get here so
how do we
stop people getting as far as they do
getting themselves to the beaches and
into the contact of those people
Smugglers and and how then do we process
genuine legitimate Asylum claims is
there another way to do this Steve
there's completely another way to do
this I mean the starting point is the
last thing that you mentioned people who
make claims should have their claims
dealt with and this country the UK has
not been doing that for the last few
years it's why a backlog has ballooned
from around ten thousand fifteen
thousand people to around a hundred
thousand people in just the space of a
few years
so we have to make our Asylum system
work work and that's by deciding the
claims of people
in terms of addressing these dangerous
Journeys look the UK needs to work with
others that's certainly true but it
needs to work with others on getting
people safely into Asylum systems not
working with others simply to try and
stop people moving and leave them in
misery I'm afraid it's not just the UK
that behaves like that but we certainly
do as a country and have done for a long
time and we are encouraging nothing that
enables people to stop making dangerous
Journeys and everything to require them
to make more Journeys rely more on
Smugglers because if none of us will
share responsibility with each other
ultimately
the only people who offer any sort of
Hope
miserable and exploitative so though it
is are those Smugglers
um Steve I'm afraid we have to leave it
there but I suspect we will be talking
again very soon Steve Valdez Simmons
from amnesty International's Refugee and
migrants rights program thank you very
much indeed
just a bit of detail um in fact a
statement in fact I'm reading from
enverse Solomon the chief executive of
the refugee Council that I think is
worth bringing in at this point he says
this we are devastated to hear news of
the incident in the channel today and
heartbroken at the reports of fatalities
our thoughts are with all those affected
and we pay tribute to the rescue teams
working on such a dreadful incident
sadly this is not the first time we are
waking up to such devastating use of
people having lost their lives on a
harrowing journey to Britain in search
of safety and Enver makes this point uh
ever from the refugee Council it is just
over a year since 32 lives were lost in
a similar incident like those involved
in today's incident they had hopes and
dreams for the future they weren't
illegal they were Desperately Seeking
safety uh the refugee Council saying
they will be monitoring the situation
carefully and in the meantime thank all
those who've expressed their sympathy
and solidarity with those affected by
this horror horrendous incident
um let's once again bring a political
correspondent tomorrow and tomorrow
you're getting some update as to as to
the detail of what has happened in the
channel yes government sources saying
that a number of people have been
rescued alive so that is very good very
good news that um the the
um or the Coast Guard and all the um
Emergency Services deployed there in the
early hours this morning were able to
get some people out alive One Source is
saying it's as many as 43 alive but
um we do not know how many people were
initially on the boat so that is yet to
be clarified but sounds like at least
some of those on the boat have been
rescued and taken to safety but sadly we
are also hearing from a number of
sources including MPS in the area that
others are feared dead but it sounds
like not everyone on the boat is in the
channel some of them have been taken to
safety so that is good news there are
there are a number of conservative MPS
who work in this area that we have been
hearing from this morning we've also
heard of course from Natalie effect that
the Dover MP Damien green out actually
sitting in the sofa just a little bit
earlier on today do you detect I mean
look let's just reiterate that point
just now that at least one source
suggesting to us that there have been a
significant number of rescues great news
if that if that proves to be true but do
you detect anything in this given you
know as as the refugee Council pointed
out we were here a year ago almost to
the day you know do you detect anything
in in this incident that will prompt
immediate Reflection from the government
given we did have a fairly significant
announcement on on immigration from the
Prime Minister yesterday we did and it
was almost a preempt a tragedy like this
happening I mean ever since Boris
Johnson was elected and the numbers of
people crossing the channel in
particular Rose so much from something
under 300 in 2018 eight and a half
thousand in 2020 and then 40 000 this
year I mean we're talking about a real
spike in people taking this particular
route the government have been saying
we're going to crack down on it under
two different home secretaries they've
tried all sorts of tactics all of last
year they were talking about and pushing
boats back and all these controversial
tactics which in the end could not be
used they found it very difficult to
stop people using these routes and Rishi
sunak is as a result of his announcement
yesterday able to say that not only has
the Home Secretary managed to agree a
deal with the French last month when she
went over there offered more money from
our side having British personnel and
French control rooms to see how it all
worked how they're disrupting the boats
before they leave but yesterday he
talked about giving the National Crime
agency more money to tackle the gangs
and legislation next year to make it
more difficult for people who make it
here to get get their Asylum claims
approved so all this is talking about
acting as a deterrent but it's all going
to take many months and when you get an
absolute tragedy like this the idea that
people would risk their lives in
Sub-Zero temperatures to cross the
channel it really does make politicians
reflect on you know the the conditions
that would make people do that and I
think many Charities will be today
pressing the case as they often do that
there are not enough safe routes there
are safe routes for people who come from
Ukraine on the particular scheme from
Afghanistan and from Hong Kong but for
many people in unstable parts of the
world whether that's people coming from
Syria and people who've not been able to
make their claim in the country
um that they they want to come from from
Iran from other places where they say
they are suffering from persecution I
mean it's very difficult to to get here
by any other route but I think the
government will fall back on what they
announced yesterday saying that the
Prime Minister has made this his
personal priority but his home secretary
said a few weeks ago none of this is the
Silver Bullet none of this is going to
stop it happening we can just try and do
things around the edges particularly in
getting through the enormous backlog of
people who've made claims and Adam
Parsons is our Europe correspondent he
joins us on the line and he is on his
way way to Cali as we speak but but you
have been there um you have been there
Adam a number of times in recent months
there's absolutely nothing that is
surprising about this incident is there
nothing at all I mean frankly everybody
has been expecting something like this
to happen I have to say honestly I I
often think I'm surprised it doesn't
happen more often because so many of
these boats leave from the beaches uh
and you see them and they are clearly
not sea worthy they're very often fitted
with engines that malfunction I've seen
those leaving beaches and the engines
are sort of spluttering and dying still
within sight of them and they are often
overloaded uh this boat appears to have
had between 40 and 50 people on board it
I can guarantee you that if you had a
choice you would not be getting on a
boat of that type with 49
um other people so no there's there's
nothing surprising about this at all
that the similar incident that happened
last year were 31 people died was
probably a culmination of a whole series
of Affairs as is this one nearly exactly
uh a year later and and frankly it's
hard to think of a more atrocious
situation to find yourself in Charities
that we've been in contact with this
morning have told us that well one of
them said that they were in contact with
somebody on the boat and they had the
last conversation they had with them was
at 253 in the morning at that point the
channel is a Inky black it would have
been very cold the waters you've been
hearing would have been freezing and
remember this is the busiest shipping
Lane uh in the world so it's a
terrifying journey to make uh and uh it
it is to my mind remarkable how many of
these small boats actually get across
the channel without going to this uh
this sort of peril but it's a measure of
of the desperation and the desire that
people have like it's a point that seems
obvious but it's worth making
everybody that you see in a migrant camp
in Calais and Dunkirk and in those areas
is only there for one reason it's not
because they like the Northwest French
Coast it's because they want to get to
Britain and they are going to try to do
so on board uh a boat it's not a
question at that point of do they fancy
it or do they not they're going to try
to get on a boat and they're going to
try and get across the channel it used
to be that at this time of the year this
sort of cross-channel migration on small
boats sort of faded away and when I say
used to be we're only talking about a
relatively short space of time but but
this year I mean about last year we've
seen a change and it's almost becoming a
year round uh exercise and of course
it's incredibly perilous to be doing
that journey in this weather
um but also the the conditions if you
exclude the the freezing temperature
yesterday it seems as if conditions were
good for taking a boat across the the
the people Smugglers they don't really
think about the temperature they're
looking at the wind and the wind is uh
is a factor here and the wind if it's
calm
um seems to have been in their favor I
have to tell you that I mean if this
number is is confirmed that 43 people uh
have been
um have been rescued that would seem to
be a really very very high number at the
fears among many people were of multiple
multiple fatalities French hospitals
have been warned that they would expect
the potential for a significant number
of fatalities if this figure correct is
a 43 rescue that will be despite the
fact that clearly people may well have
died in this that will be a a really
sort of pleasingly high number of people
to have been taken from an incident of
this kind
yeah it will it certainly will land him
but I believe the last time we were
talking was when you were on the beaches
of Cali was when there was that
announcement of a close-up UK France
Partnership of of Greater information
sharing of of British officers being in
the control room on the French site has
that joint cooperation not delivered any
benefits just yet or is it can we detect
any Improvement as a result of that or
has it just not had enough time to bed
in
I think a a it's in its infancy
um but B you do come back to some
fundamental questions here which are
that these people are trying to get
across that they are empowered to an
extent by people's Smugglers and let's
run over the people's models are earning
a lot of money from this the people at
the top of these these criminal
Enterprises are millionaires and they
are making fortunes from this and it's a
it's a cat and mouse game so it is not
so long ago that we a matter of weeks
that we filmed
um migrants running down the beach into
the water and jumping in into boats that
were just off the the short why were
they doing that it's because the French
police is standing order say they can't
enter the sea to intercept people they
can't arrest people Smugglers who are
out at Sea and so this almost sort of
taxi service it used to be we saw
migrants running down the beach carrying
boats and and collectively throwing them
in the water and getting in now they
they've discovered people Smugglers
discovered it's a lot easier if they
bring a boat around and get people to
run into the water for them and it's a
good example of how they are Adept at
circumnavigating the rules that that are
put in front of them however criminal
however evil we may portray these people
as being they often smart at
understanding what needs to be done and
as the police move the goal posts in One
Direction the Smugglers uh react so yes
there will be more police but remember
also uh the number of people attempting
to cross the channel has gone up so if
you increase the number of police who
are trying to stop them you are
effectively in terms of a you know my
desperate migrant per police officer the
ratio probably hasn't changed that much
Adam Parson said thanks very much indeed
all our sources are telling us that that
43 people have been rescued alive there
have been at least three people losing
their lives following this this incident
this major instance taking place in the
channel and let's speak now to Kevin
Saunders uh former Chief immigration
officer at the UK border force in Cali
good to see you this morning wish it was
under different circumstances of course
what do you make of the the detail of
the the rescue effort that is going on
at the moment the scale of it the
multi-agency approach that is being
taken I mean dear goodness is a fishing
boat there's french navy there's UK Navy
it's all coming together and and it
would appear going by the number of
people rescued that it has borne fruit
yes it would and if they have rescued 43
people that's a fantastic result and it
shows how well that the UK and France
can work together when there's a tragedy
like this so yeah it's a great result
it's still tragic the three people
um have died so far
um but it is it's fantastic that 43 have
been saved particularly is the weather
so awful
just just describe to us what the
conditions at this type of time of year
would generally be like but no one in
the middle of an Arctic Storm at the
moment but but even without that I mean
crossing the channel was perilous what's
pedalus at any time of the year isn't it
yes I've been crossing the channel you
know in a small boat like this is
absolute sheer Madness at any time of
the year but in in the winter with the
sea temperature being what it is and we
saw uh the tragic death at the weekend
of those small children Kevin can I just
get you to to pause just for a second
um because I think if you can see your
screen right now if you can see what I'm
seeing we are looking at the rescue
itself I'm just going to try and move
myself to slightly closer to the
television so I can actually make it out
a bit more I mean that is that is
clearly an inflatable craft it is an
inflatable craft that I think if I'm
looking at it correctly here that that
is folded up on itself that looks to me
like an awful lot of people balancing on
the edge and stuck wedged almost in the
middle of that but I mean have you seen
anything like this
never I've never seen anything like that
at all it would seem that perhaps the
boat didn't capsize but actually
um got a puncher in it because these
things are filled with air so it looks
from that picture as though some of the
um air cylinders have um
have punctured and the boats started to
folding on itself it must be incredibly
frightening for the people on board
because they don't all seem to be
wearing life jackets either
but but again just just ticking and this
is this is very much the most the first
look that I've had at this picture same
as yourself you look at the individual
that is sitting Atop The Edge of the the
boat and almost in the center of the
frame at the very very top there yes
waiting a short sleeved shirt you know
presumably in the wee hours of the
morning whilst crossing the channel I
mean you'll have seen that I suspect
more than once
yes I mean that that's that's that's the
sheer and other Madness short sleeve
shirt in this weather coming across the
channel is going to be soaking wet
um it's just absolutely utter Madness it
really is
what is your view then as to to where we
should be targeting our resources to
prevent this now as we said we
understand that you know 43 people have
been have been rescued alive which is
fantastic
but three people have died we're now
looking at one of the other in fact is
the Lifeboat from the Dungeness station
I can just make out uh there and that's
them recovering the the recovering the
boat uh proper I think I think maybe one
person perhaps still still in inside it
where do we need to be focusing our
resources do we need to be stopping
people getting to the beaches of Cali do
we need to be targeting the people
Smugglers themselves where is the
solution to this it's both we've got to
Target The People's Smugglers and the
extra money for the NCA that the Prime
Minister announced yesterday will be
very helpful but we've also got to stop
people getting onto the channel and
risking life and live because not only
are they rescuing their their sorry not
alone are they risking their lives
The Rescuers are risking their lives as
well
and we are going to see this again
aren't we unless some pretty significant
action is taken and taken immediately
Kevin is that is that fair to say that
that's I mean last year I was in Dover
last year when the uh disaster happened
last year and I said then this will
happen again and unfortunately it has
we have to stop the people coming from
the beaches we just have to do it and if
we have to throw more money at it so be
it
but we can't have we can't have people
um risking their lives like this it's
just immoral basically
it it it it certainly is and one
incident that that we have been reminded
of this morning by by the refugee
Council nor less is the one that took
place you know roughly the same time
last year in which more than 30 people
lost their lives and that wasn't enough
for there to be changes to ensure that
it didn't happen again
no it it didn't and it's very sad that
it didn't the trouble is that um
the French interpretation of the law of
the sea is different from ours
so I don't blame the French they can
only operate within what they see as the
law so they can't do they can't
intercept the people on the channel
although that's what would stop it if
they could
um so it's got to be more people on the
beaches the government are doing things
like putting people into the French
um control
um the headquarters that cat green a
so that's a positive move the end moves
that um the Prime Minister announced
yesterday again
they're helpful they're not the Silver
Bullet but they are helpful
if we get something on Rwanda that will
be helpful they're small steps got a lot
of small steps might just work out
Uh Kevin Saunders uh many thanks indeed
Santa as you look at the picture there
swella bravaman uh quotes at the bottom
of the screen we will be hearing from
the home sector in a step into those of
Commons at around about half past 12 my
colleague Jane second is in the studio
Neil thanks very much uh if you're just
joining us uh we can bring in the news
that Sky News understands that the
number of people that have been
recovered on this small boat between 30
and 50 when it went down in the channel
Searchers will continue all day but at
this stage sources say 43 people were
rescued from the boat three people are
known to have died it is feared of
course that more could have perished
the incident happened and these are
images of it around halfway between the
Kent coast and the coast of France
to Search and Rescue helicopters plus a
french navy helicopter RNA lifeboats and
other UK and French Navy boats have all
been involved in that rescue joining me
now Sky correspondent Tamara Cohen uh
tomorrow what more can you tell us so
what we're hearing is that while it
sounds clear that there have been some
fatalities we're hearing at least three
fatalities from this awful incident it
sounds as if a significant number of
people may have been rescued even in
those freezing conditions if we just
look at that picture I mean and we were
hearing from the former border Force
Chief Kevin Saunders that he's not seen
anything like this before it doesn't
look as if the boat has necessarily
capsized it's kind of fallen in on
itself as if maybe he said it had a
puncture so we're yet to get to the
bottom of what actually happened to the
this boat because although it was
absolutely freezing last night the
conditions were said to be calm so they
obviously set sail thinking they had a
chance of making it a sent to the UK so
it sounds as if a significant number of
people have thankfully been rescued and
taken to safety but some people in those
freezing conditions last night appear to
have died this is a tragedy the worst
tragedy that's happened in the channel
since last November when we know that 30
people lost their lives when a boat
capsized and we've heard since about the
Frantic calls made to Emergency Services
it sounds as if the Emergency Services
were on the scene very quickly in the
early hours of this morning but is again
going to put a focus on this small boat
tissue and the really dramatic increase
in the number of people taking this
route
and Amanda acass also joins us on the
studio Manor this is an area you know
well that you've reported from
um what do you think the reaction will
be locally clearly a lot of local people
have been involved in this rescue well
absolutely you just look at the number
of people who volunteer for the
lifeboats getting called out in the
middle of the night in these freezing
conditions going out there in the dark
searching for what could well be Many
Bodies In The Water
um it sounds as you were saying tomorrow
that indeed they managed to get to the
scene incredibly quickly in order to
pick people up
um you can see there in the pictures
that people aren't wearing
um proper waterproof worn clothing
clothing many of them not wearing life
jackets indeed I've covered a number of
cases in the past where only the
Smugglers were wearing jackets and you
could have 20 or 30 40 people crammed
onto these tiny boats which often are
only designed for say 12 people to be on
board and Clinging On And if there are
any problems with the boats which
clearly are massively overloaded
um sometimes it's just at the end engine
fails and then they get swamped by the
waves or there could be a puncture or
there could be another problem with the
boat obviously it is the world's biggest
busiest shipping Lane as well so quite
often these huge cargo ships the ferries
going backwards and forwards don't see
these tiny boats in in the channel they
can get swamped by their waves as well
but it does indeed seem that they were
within British Waters and when they got
into difficulty were able to alert the
authorities who seem to have mounted a
very efficient rescue operation getting
onto the scene although of course as we
we understand that there have been at
least three people who have died I know
in the past there were awful incidents
where people have been swept overboard
as well
um which is something that can sometimes
happen because obviously when you are
going into this into the sea like that
in the middle of the night in the dark
in freezing conditions
um you really are at the mercy of the
conditions out there I think as as you
mentioned the incident last year which
really I think was a huge shock for all
local communities who've been used to
seeing many many more of these boats
arriving on the beaches or people being
brought ashore by the lifeboats and and
Border Force Cutters at Dover we see all
those photographs of people coming on
Shore being looked after and I think
that instant last year really reminded
people what the risks are and once again
now we're in the winter previously when
this first started happening we only saw
boats doing that Crossing in the summer
months when it was very calm good
conditions now clearly people are trying
to do the journey all year round and and
you can see how very dangerous that is
at this time
um let's bring in now uh Claire Mosley
from the care for Calais charity which
is a refugee charity working with
refugees in the UK and France and Claire
what will the last few days have been
like for these people who are on this
boat what are the steps that that they
go through before they embark on this
journey
well very sadly they probably would have
been full of hate
um they
hope that they are coming to the UK to
start a new life
um that the people who have come from
the very worst things in the world from
war zones from places where they have
been persecuted and tortured and they
believe that they're coming to the UK to
finally reach safety
um it's unbelievably tragic that right
on the cusp of being able to achieve
safety and start a new life that they
could die right at the very end of their
Journey
um it's unbelievably tragic
and it's really horrible for us to think
just three weeks ago we were in London
for the vigil with the families of those
people who died just a year ago
seeing their
unbelievable grief that hasn't
diminished in the slightest
hearing how they spoke about their
family members who drowned a year ago I
really I don't have the words to convey
to you just how awful that was seeing
more pain seeing how raw it still is
feeling their loss and now knowing that
there's going to be at least three more
families now going through that same
pain and grief the same questions the
same despair the same heartache same
questions I just I can't bear to think
that there's now going to be another
three families and extended families in
in that same state of upset and loss
and and Claire you know as you say we
are just a year on from from that that
Dreadful loss of life in the channel and
what is clear is that that has not
deterred people from making this journey
and it's not deterred them from making
it in the most appalling conditions
it's not and it's not going to I mean
that that is that the whole point about
refugees isn't it the things that they
are coming from are safe very awful the
journeys that they've made are so
horrendous and so harrowing the risks
that they've had to take to get this far
are so massive that by the time they get
here that journey is just one more risk
it's one more risk that they take to
justify if you liked it to to fulfill
the risks that they've already taken
they're in a state of Minds there is so
desperate they're so at the end of their
tether they've already overcome so much
that it it is just one more risk and
that's the whole that is what it's like
to be a refugee being a refugee is is an
awful existence it means it's terrible
terrible things have happened to you it
means that you are on the cusp of
reaching safety
um there could not be people that need
our help more than refugees they are
people who have seen their families
killed in conflicts they're people who
have suffered extreme torture they're
people who might have been persecuted
for years they really are nobody in the
world that needs our help more than
refugees
um the statistics that the government
recently released show that the
nationalities and the people that we're
working within Cali
80 and 90 of them are having an exercise
and claims accepted when they reach the
UK because of the terrible things that
they have suffered you know the facts
and the data and everything that I
experience will tell you that these are
people who have suffered absolutely
horrendous things there cannot be people
who need our help more
and it's really devastating to know that
a year on from that terrible tragedy
that happened when 32 people lost our
lives our government has taken no steps
whatsoever to help these people you know
it would be so easy for us to reach out
and help them and collate there are
things that can be done and instead all
the policies that our government is
looking at all the things that were not
talked about yesterday are simply things
that are targeted at keeping them out at
making sure that we do not have any
responsibility for them but we don't
take any steps to help them when it
would be so easy for us to do so you
know we could offer safe passage to
people in Calais in the same way that we
did with ukrainians who we gave them
safe passage across the channel nobody
would need to risk their lives and we
did it for ukrainians so there's no
reason that we can't do it for other
refugees and at a sweep that would put
the people Smugglers out of business
that would mean that nobody is risking
their lives this is also completely
unnecessary it doesn't need to happen
maybe really needs to rest their lives
and as I say we have all the status to
show that they are genuine refugees in
real need of our health and there
couldn't be anybody that we need to help
more than these people so why can't we
just offer them safe passage we did it
for ukrainians the system is there it's
in place we know it works we know that
no ukrainians got on small boats we know
no ukrainians pay people Smugglers so
you know we have it right in front of us
and a year on after seeing 32 people
lose their lives nobody is willing to
consider it and nobody is willing to
discuss it and I find that very hard to
take and now it's happened again we knew
it would happen again and now it has
okay Claire Mosley from care for Calais
charity thank you very much for joining
us if you're just joining us these are
the latest images that we have of this
rescue we know that the rnli and also uh
they're all Navy and Border Force
vessels were involved in the rescue of
this boat initially described as a small
boat but then it became clear that it
was a larger vessel but we can see the
images of it and it isn't that big at
all it is an inflatable craft mercifully
43 people uh were rescued alive from it
three are known to have perished fear
that it could be many more but when we
see the size of the boat it is
astonishing that 43 people were able to
survive that in terms of The Wider
picture the numbers of people coming
across the channel over the last year
the latest figures show that are up
until yesterday
44
711 had crossed the channel on board
small boats this year they traveled in
on just over a thousand boats a thousand
and 87 boats an average of 41 people per
vessel it is a huge increase on last
year when they were just 28
526 arrivals over the whole 12-month
period
well the Home Secretary is going to make
a statement to the House of Commons at
12 30. we're doing now by the
conservative MP for Dover and deal that
is an area of course normally affected
by this Natalie elfic and Natalie what
are your thoughts today
well I'm very very saddened to hear of
this tragedy in the channel today
um waking up to the news that I fear as
the MP for Dover and deal day after day
lives lost a number saved only 43 saved
only due to the bravery and
professionalism of the Rescue Services
that operate out of Dover and along our
East Kent coast and I have I have to you
know pay tribute to their bravery and
thank them for their rescue mission this
morning in absolutely treacherous wintry
conditions
it must have been a horrific call out at
three o'clock wasn't it
um in terms of what the solution is what
would you like to see the government do
well as I've said now uh time and again
it is a matter of great urgency that the
boats have stopped entering the water
from France uh people are safe in France
this is illegal criminality organized
crime through and through that number of
people crossing now uh very near to 45
000 people that's the result of
industrial illegal immigration by
organized criminal gangs operating on
the shores of France it is urgent that
the Prime Minister who is taking
personal responsibility for this issue
has a summit with president macron and
that action is taken to bring this to an
end before we have further loss of life
in the channel
we spoke to Claire Mosley from the care
for Calais charity just a moment ago she
said one wait waiters get the boats to
not go in the water in France would be
to set up a center in northern France
and offer safe passage to those who who
believe that they have a strong claim
would that not be a solution
unfortunately organizations like care
for Calais are part of the problem not
the solution in dealing with the channel
Crossings care for Kelly is one of the
organizations that's taking legal action
against the government and is not I
think really looking out for those
solutions that would be in the best
interests of people who are in the hands
of these criminal gangs and often also
in crime here in the UK once they are
smuggled in and involved in modern
slavery and we've got to you know really
be clear that those organizations are
blocking the attempts of the government
to be trying to bring an end to the
small boats and crossings it is vital
that they really look at the interests
of people in the hands of criminal gangs
encourage them not to take these
Journeys that are so dangerous and do
result unfortunately and sadly in loss
of life encourage people instead to ask
France for Refugee assistance if they
are in need of it or any other country
before they reach France who is party to
the same Refugee conventions and also to
make it really really clear that the
majority of people who have been
traveling by the small boats arriving in
Britain in recent weeks are albanians
from a safe country and who are not in
need of Refuge or Asylum and it's
absolutely vital that we take action and
bring an end to this and stop these
criminal gangs who are ruthless and do
not care if they are risking lives in
the pursuit of their illegal crime
do you dispute the figures that she
provided as we know that there is a a
particular problem with albanians
traveling across in recent weeks but the
figure that she quoted eighty percent of
those who reached the UK on these small
boats are actually granted Asylum
well we know that our system in the UK
is in need of Reform and the Prime
Minister yesterday set out his
five-point plan for tackling that which
included
as far as you understand it is that is
that a correct representation of the
facts that 80 of those who have come
across on the small boats are eventually
granted Asylum well we know that once
people are in the UK it is extremely
difficult to do anything but for the
majority of people to stay in the UK and
that is why it is such a strong magnet
for people to come in through illegal
routes and try to get to Britain that's
why we have to be very very clear that
illegal immigration is not acceptable
that we do have but we do if I can
finish but we do we do have resettlement
schemes that we operate with the United
Nations where we bring people directly
from conflict areas and there are over a
hundred million people displaced around
the globe the right way to deal with
Refugee and Asylum is to make sure that
we have the systems and processes and
support in place to help people we do
that as the Prime Minister said
yesterday more humanitarian visas have
been issued than since the second world
war we are a generous country but this
is about illegal organized crime and if
we want to help people who are in need
of assistance they should not be taking
this incredibly dangerous Crossing we've
seen lives lost again today we've got to
bring it to an end but their point is of
course that you say that they are
illegal but if 80 of them are granted
asylum in the UK it shows that they had
a valid case which therefore means that
they are not illegal they had a valid
case for Asylum and they would argue
that because there aren't the safe
routes that they're able to use they've
been forced to take this action with
many Charities that any British
government had more safe routes then
they wouldn't have to get on the small
boats
there are safe routes eventually we have
issued as the UK more humanitarian visas
than since the second world war there
are safe passage routes there are
applications for work visas which
hundreds of thousands of people take
there are education visas they're our
family reunion visas that you can apply
in the UK from a room and a computer in
the UK so no family member needs to get
into a boat or be in the hands of
illegal immigration illegal entry to the
UK is a crime it is not the way to come
to the UK the UK does have resettlement
and Asylum programs it does give a
tremendous amount of support around the
globe as well as to people who settle
here in the UK and it's absolutely vital
that those two issues are not confused
to do so just drives up more illegal
immigration we need to tackle this at
source and recognize this for the
illegal activity that it is that our
safe and legal routes to come to the UK
and people must take those they must not
risk their lives or indeed lose their
lives in the wintry sea in the channel
I'm good to talk to you today thank you
very much for joining us Natalie elfic
they're the the MP for that patch most
affected it's fair to say by these
Crossings in these boats and we can see
these images of this boat that traveled
across the sea last night in really
really cold conditions mobilization of
the rnli and the Border force and the
Royal Navy to rescue the people that
were on this boat three people have died
we know 43 were rescued let's bring in
our correspondence here in the studio
I'm joined by Sky correspondents
tomorrow tomorrow Cohen and Amanda Acres
tomorrow to you first of all we saw the
Prime Minister make this this extensive
speech yesterday about trying to tackle
this very problem but this will put more
pressure on him won't it that's right
and if we were expecting this to be some
kind of watershed moment in our policy
towards small boats I don't think that's
going to happen the politics of it are
set out by Natalie elfick the MP for
Dover many conservatives think that
those Charities who work with refugees
season and are pushing for them to be
for there to be more safe routes you say
that there aren't the safe routes there
for people to apply safely otherwise
they that's why they're putting their
lives in the hands of these people
Smugglers and these small boats in
freezing conditions
um Tory MPS as you heard there think
that they're part of the problem and
Rishi sunak set out yesterday what's
intended to be a tough approach
um to say that he wants there to be a
number of deterrents um in the shape of
threats to send people back to certain
countries like Albania threats to send
people to Rwanda and the Home Secretary
sowella brothman who will be speaking in
Parliament on this at lunchtime is a
hardliner she described the migrant
boats arriving on the UK stores as an
invasion very controversially back at
the Party Conference in September so
look I think they'll fall back on what
they said yesterday saying the Prime
Minister has taken personal charge and
he's very energized about this issue but
everything he suggested yesterday is
going to take many months to to have any
impact he's talking about legislative
Nation to stop the modern slavery act
being abused he's talking about more
money from the National Crime agency so
it can tackle the people smuggling gangs
and he did also touch on working with
other countries because of course that's
the key to this um he met last week the
Calais group France Germany Belgium um
to talk about what actually they can
take together but you know many people
will say that's the key you have to work
with other countries on this because
just taking action here in the UK
um is first of all not that effective as
the Home Secretary admitted herself it's
not a silver bullet and this people will
continue to risk their lives as they are
in increasing numbers I mean we've had
record numbers this year 44 000 it was
only about 300 back in 2018.
um so the measures that he announced
yesterday are intended to sound tough
but I think many Charities would say
that they are the wrong place to be
looking
tomorrow and we're just going to bring
you the latest images that we have and
this is actually moving footage that we
have of the rescue uh this is moving
footage obviously taken from the same
angle as the still pictures that we saw
earlier uh you can see the helicopter
there up in the sky trying to illuminate
the scene to try and help the situation
for those on the Lifeboat on the ground
on the water pulling those people off
that boat
another bit of breaking news that we can
bring you on an unrelated story and this
is about the explosion that happened in
Jersey over the weekend we know that the
Emergency Services there said that they
had given up hope of finding any
survivors it was a recovery operation
they have confirmed this morning excuse
me that one further fatality has been
confirmed at that site that is now eight
people who have died in that blast in
Jersey and the authorities in Jersey
believe that one person there is still
unaccounted for one resident that they
are still looking for not expecting to
find any survivors but they have now
found the remains of an eighth person in
that explosion that rocked at this quiet
town over the weekend
well let's return to the breaking news
this morning that there has been a
significant boat rescue in the English
Channel overnight let's bring an Amanda
acass our correspondent here and and
Amanda this is an area you've reported
from it extensively in the past
um what what do you think that the
ramifications of this are for for those
living in that area do you think it will
change anything tomorrow said that she
didn't think it was going to be a
particularly watershed moment
I think tragically really people in that
area of Kent and the south coast in
Sussex as well they've become very used
to this to seeing the boats arriving on
the beaches
um walking up and down Beauty spots
finding the remains of boats where
people have arrived and um and been able
to to make their own way on into the
rest of the country but more generally
people being rescued by the iron alive
being picked up by those border Force
Cutters and being brought into Dover and
processed and then
um and taken on from there while people
put in their Asylum claims
um I think there are many Charities as
we've been hearing who work with people
on both sides of the channel and I think
particularly they're a key issue here is
about the relationship with the French
authorities we often hear from many MPS
in Kent that the French should be doing
more there was quite a there wasn't a
particularly enthusiastic welcome for
that deal that was announced by Rishi
sunak and Sora bravman a few weeks ago
of Greater cooperation greater funding
for the French authorities to allow more
joint working with UK border Force
officers working alongside their French
counterparts and we heard Mr sunac
yesterday in the comments talking about
the additional patrols on the French
beaches now French politicians
um often point the finger at the UK
authorities and say not enough is done
here to prevent people working illegally
for example we don't have identity cards
as we do in the continent and they
believe that's a draw factor and they
say well actually UK authorities need to
think quite differently about our
approach that's obviously a row that
goes on between politicians of the two
Nations I think perhaps what one aspect
of this that perhaps might become more
difficult over time as we saw when more
funding was pumped into protecting the
channel tunnel and the port the ferry
terminals building a lot of money was
pumped in millions and millions into
building new fences and putting up extra
security there and that's partly will
stop people getting onto the lorries and
the trains and move them towards taking
this much more dangerous approach in
terms of the small boats there are Miles
and Miles of beaches in quite remote
areas in northern France
um it is difficult to to keep that
patrolled all the time equally as we see
more and more resources diverted to that
you could potentially see more people
trying to make that Crossing at night as
we've just seen and in the kind of
conditions where you really know really
doesn't seem like it would be the best
time to be attempting this journey in
freezing conditions like this and Amanda
I want to say that these people have
been rescued what will happen to them we
obviously saw there was a lot of
publicity a few weeks ago about the
manston center where a lot of people
were going that was eventually emptied
this is another concern for local people
isn't it that all of a sudden there's a
whole load of new people coming into
their area what would be the general
pattern that would happen when on
someone has been rescued on a boat like
this yes absolutely so they are they are
taken and they are initially assessed um
and then that was what manston was all
about really carrying out those
assessments because so many people
arrived at the same time
um that's why there were these long
delays keeping people detained
um then people put their applications in
and have to wait as we know the backlog
nearly 150 000 people waiting um nearly
a hundred thousand of those waiting more
than six months so people are generally
given accommodation
um many of them in hotels that we heard
a lot yesterday from the government
saying that's costing them 5.5 million
pounds a day and that's why they're Keen
to look at other options accommodation
in military Barracks just use holiday
Parks former University accommodation
and and so on
um that's not simple either
um and I think particularly because
people are arriving the southeast many
are accommodated in the Southeast Napier
Barracks for example it was used as a
place where people stayed for many years
had big problems with covert outbreaks
fire as all kinds of issues with the
local community weren't happy about that
being there and I think we're going to
see that in other areas where potential
military bases and holiday camps are
being used the other issue of course is
the children the under 18s because they
the like any under 18 the local
Authority has a duty to care for them to
provide them with foster care or to look
after them in de facto children's homes
that that is a a an expensive
complicated thing to do Kent over many
years were bearing much of that burden
now there's a new system where other
authorities have to take their share but
I think in that has caused other
problems as well because in other parts
of the country they're not used to doing
that and that's caused some friction
with local communities uh worried about
the division of resources so it's not a
simple issue and that's why for the
government they're getting sick they've
had such pressure from their own MPS to
try and find a solution to reduce those
numbers but clearly there are many many
desperate people out there who um are
continuing to make our journey and
tomorrow very briefly
um we're expecting a statement from the
Home Secretary immediately after prime
minister's questions yes we are we're
expecting her to give us an update
potentially on what exactly happened and
the numbers of people rescued and the
numbers of people who have we understand
have sadly lost their lives so we'll get
more from the Home Secretary who tweeted
this morning that she was being kept in
touch with developments to try and work
out exactly what had gone on but the the
question for her and for Richie sunac is
there are plenty of conservative back
benches who see this in very Stark terms
they want to stop boats coming across
the channel and they look to the current
prime minister and the last prime
minister and the one before that who
told them that this was possible that
they could stop boats coming across the
channel when in fact you know there were
no real silver bullets you can you can
take measures to try and tackle it and
you can take measures to try and provide
a deterrent but you know we had
conservative MPS telling us on camera
last night that they think they'll lose
the next election if the government does
not tackle this small boat issue that's
why obviously not rushed forward this
announcement yesterday which I
understood was intended for the new year
he knew a lot of people are concerned
about it
um people will be even more concerned
now with Today's tragedy but
um I think the the tough approach is
what a lot of people in his party want
to see and um you know many will say
cynically that they are the audience for
for these measures yesterday the tough
sounding measures
um when of course um you know a lot of
people who come over here have their
Asylum claims approved okay tomorrow
thank you very much good morning if
you're just joining us it is just after
11 o'clock you are watching Sky News and
we are staying with our breaking news
the three people have died and at least
43 have been rescued after a major
incident in the channel a major search
and rescue operation is still underway
after reports of a boat going down just
before four o'clock this morning
the operation in the channel is a joint
effort between the Royal Navy the French
navy the Coast Guard and the rnli
now the latest pictures that we have of
the rescue that is an rnli Lifeboat as
you can see with latest moving pictures
that we have uh helicopters were
involved also helping illuminate the
scene and the conditions at that time
four o'clock in the morning on what
everybody here knows is it has been a
freezing cold night uh really really
difficult and quite astonishing really
that 43 people were rescued alive when
that boat got into difficulties join me
now Sky correspondents Tamara Cohen and
Amanda acass let's start with our
political correspondents tomorrow Cohen
and tomorrow we had this massive
announcement from the Prime Minister
yesterday to try to tackle this problem
um is there anything in what he has said
that that can be brought in swiftly to
to try to avert these kind of things
happening again none of it's going to
happen overnight I mean what she's
saying that was talking about yesterday
was essentially deterrence of the more
than 40 000 people who have come over
the channel in small boats this year
year thirteen thousand of them about a
third or Albanian and the Prime Minister
and other MPS have been concerned that
that is a safe country
um so people should not be making Asylum
claims as they would form a war-torn
country and so he was talking about
speeding up agreements to send them back
there although that has been tried by
previous home secretaries for some time
he's also talked about getting the
Rwanda scheme up and money running which
is currently tied up in the courts and
no one knows if anyone will ever be
taken to Rwanda so that was one part of
it but he's also responding to concerns
about the way that local councils have
had to take over hotels in order to put
up people who are waiting for their
claims to be processed and the urgent
need to both get through that backlog
with more staff working on it and to put
people up in different uh different
accommodation as Amanda was just saying
but I think what many MPS will be
pressing putting their hopes on
especially as we think about the next
election is that legislation coming
forward next year
um to try and clamp down on on some of
these things but that is going to take
months it's going to be just potentially
amended by people in Parliament so look
none of it's going to be a silver bullet
but the Prime Minister did announce more
funding for the National Crime agency as
well to tackle criminal gangs so he'll
say he's pursuing all the available
options but certainly they are not good
and he has also set himself a very high
bar saying he wants to stop the boat
stop the boat to something he's often
said and you know it's hard to see how
certainly in the short term that is
going to really happen I mean people if
people are willing to take these
desperate Journeys the French
authorities can't control Patrol
hundreds of miles of Coastline although
they've had more money from the UK this
year to ramp up what they are what they
are doing but um this is going to
continue to happen and
um it's it's hard to see how you can
take yourself a target of not having
anyone Crossing those boats when you
look at how it has spiked in in recent
years I mean when they started
collecting figures on this property in
2018 there were under 300 people coming
that route people came other routes
through lorries and so on then it was
about eight and a half thousand in 2020
and now it's over 40 000 and yes other
European countries do have more than
that but it's something that has
increased dramatically and it's
something the government is really
scrambling to respond to responses that
we have had already uh this morning have
been from the Home Secretary in the
shadow Home Secretary the Home Secretary
has released this statement she says I
am aware of a distressing incident in
the channel this morning and I'm being
kept constantly updated while agencies
respond and urgently establish the full
facts my heartfelt thoughts are with all
of those involved
the shadow Home Secretary Yvette Cooper
tweeted awful distressing reports from
the channel this morning
thinking of all those involved thank you
to all the agency and rescue service
teams who are responding to this
immensely difficult situation
and Amanda acass that that is a point
that Yvette Cooper makes isn't it that
this has required a big response again
in the middle of the night from local
Services obviously the Navy involved
border Force involved but also the rnli
stuff by volunteers absolutely and I
think that is you know really key part
in all of this if we're having you know
nearly 45 000 people in the past year
making that Crossing for most of those
um those boats end up calling to the
emergency services once they're in
British Waters it's part of the the
model if you like um that many of the
the people Smugglers use they don't
really need to deliver people safely all
the way across quite often what happens
at certainly in many cases that I've
covered in the courts um they will they
will make a phone call once they know
they're in British Waters and then they
know that they can come and and be
picked up and that's very difficult
because obviously our authorities have a
duty to to save the lives of people at
Sea
um and for the volunteers of the rnli
it's obviously extremely distressing
they are being called out many many are
many many incidents as you say there
might be a home they might be at work on
this occasion and indeed many at night
at home with their families dashing down
being scrambled out there in in in
dangerous situations for them quite
often if it's difficult conditions in
the channel rough and cold trying to
find people and pull them on board
often when you see the boats coming
coming in they get brought on some
occasions I've been down there when
there's multiple boats up to a dozen
sort of all coming in at once and it's
very difficult how do they spread their
resources in order to reach everyone and
then you have these lifeboats coming in
themselves absolutely packed to the
gunnels with people that they've managed
to rescue thankfully in most cases they
they miraculously do manage to get to
people but I think what was interesting
in the announcement we had yesterday
from um Rishi sunak is that there's
going to be this new sort of command for
the English Channel they say they're
going to employ another 700 people it's
going to bring together civilian and
Military authorities and kind of free up
in a border Force to focus more on the
kind of enforcement activity and so on
in terms of more raids on the gangs and
so on
um which I think I don't know what that
will necessarily mean for the rnli But
ultimately they are the first line of
this and they're the ones that you know
they know the sea they get to people
most quickly they're right there I think
there's only one or two Cutters that are
there the the naval ships um so in terms
of the resources if you're having that
many boats then you know it's a lot of
people that you need to be able to get
onto the channel and scramble to pull
you know 43 people out of the water yeah
Amanda thanks very much let's bring in
our correspondent Lisa Holland um uh
Lisa you've spoken to many of those who
who make these perilous Journeys and
really seeing these moving images
showing people willing to to make this
journey in the conditions that it was
last night really shows the scale of the
problem doesn't it
it does but I mean I suppose the million
dollar question is what impact will it
have and you know as it happens Jane I
was talking to an Albanian man yesterday
who crossed the channel in a small boat
in the summer and we were talking about
the measures that were announced by the
government yesterday to try to deter
albanians in particular from crossing
the channel and when I asked him with
regard to that political announcement
would that stop you um would that stop
albanians trying to come and he said
well frankly to be honest no if people
have the will and they have in their
minds specifically a final destination
um and namely the UK rather than trying
to claim asylum in France then they will
go that extra mile and attempt to cross
the channel it's always worth bearing in
mind when you talk about Asylum Seekers
that so often people ask the question
well why don't they claim Asylum when
they reach a safe country why don't they
claim asylum in France why do they
undertake this dangerous Channel
Crossing and often the answer is because
they have family or they have a diaspora
in the UK that they want to reach they
have relative
um in communities they they almost have
a kind of community that they want to
get to so that's why they go this extra
mile they know that it's a dangerous
Crossing and they know that they will be
packed onto boats often without life
jackets they know that right now
conditions are really really cold and
actually just talking to some people
down on the south coast
um the estimate is that if anyone was in
the water they probably would only have
been able to survive for about 15 or 20
minutes and that in reality the air
temperature that people would have been
experiencing was probably about minus
four and yes we know it's very very cold
but it was also quite calm on the
channel last night and and that's the
point is that they look for a window of
opportunity for good weather for a calm
Crossing so they can try to limit the
risk of being on such a small boat on
such a busy Waterway but will it stop
people from coming no there will be
shock amongst the Asylum Seeker
Community but we know from the disaster
last year that people still kept on
coming I think there will be a wider
political response from those who
campaign within within the Asylum
seeking community that the debate has to
be had about why there are insufficient
safe and legal routes the government
keeps saying people should use safe and
legal routes but the statistics show
there are really not that many places
available via safe and legal routes so
when you talk to people who come from
countries such as Iran or Afghanistan
they say that they have little option
but to try to go that extra mile and
come Overland and then try to cross the
channel and put themselves In Harm's Way
as we saw happened overnight last night
um and Lisa also I mean you know when
you think who in their right mind would
get on a freezing boat in the dark on an
icy night like that when the
temperatures are down to minus four but
when you think about the numbers that
are coming across over 40 000 and and a
a small very small proportion of that
very large number actually perish I I
guess a lot of people will look at the
statistics and think actually my odds
are pretty good
yeah I I think you're absolutely right
Jane and the other thing which is worth
pointing out is it's such a tried and
tested route
um you look at this enormous response
that we've seen overnight Lifeboat
cruise from Dover Dungeness
um I believe Ramsgate Hastings
um the the UK Navy border force and
French vessels as well
um that because so many people are
crossing there is this
um support system if you like and I know
that Asylum Seekers have told me in the
past that basically they're told that
once they get into UK Waters they have
the number for the Coast Guard to call
um and then they will say essentially
um we're in UK Waters and then it's it's
um down to the UK authorities who will
go and get them which is prompted
accusations in the past for example that
the RNA live had to defend themselves
against those who described them as a
almost like a taxi service at Sea
um obviously the rnl I would say you
know our job is to save lives at Sea and
that's exactly what they um have been
doing overnight but the fact that there
is this big response shows you
um just how much Focus there is in the
channel right now and Asylum Seekers
know that they know that equally if they
do get into trouble
um there's a reasonable chance that
there will be some kind of rescue vessel
who will come to assist them
Lisa thanks very much for bringing us
that
let's talk now to Bethany Gardner Smith
chief executive of safe passage now that
Champions the rights of refugees as they
flee persecution uh Bethany I don't know
if you managed to catch her interview
with the local MP Natalie elfig a little
earlier uh she was talking about
Charities such as yourselves and care
for Calais and saying that that that
your Charities are part of the problem
but not the solution because you're
blocking the attempts of the government
uh when they try to remove people from
this country who've come here through
these irregular routes what would you
say to that
but I think that's quite irresponsible
actually in terms of those comments I
mean what we do as a charity is to work
with refugees in northern France at the
moment many of whom are unaccompanied
children to try and find safe
alternatives for them including safe
routes to the UK but actually the
reality is we've just heard from your
correspondent is that there are very few
available and actually many of the safe
routes that refugees were able to access
have have since been closed down let me
give you an example we work with
children in northern France in Calais
all the time a couple of years ago
um those who had family here in the UK
we would be able to work with them to
gather evidence to submit a visa
application to come and and join their
family here and we would be able to put
them on the Eurostar and they would
arrive and be able to hug their loved
ones now many of those children have no
safe option and therefore they're
turning to the Smugglers who will put
them in these in in these flimsy
dinghies in the most appalling of
circumstances and they will be arriving
in Dover and to go into one of those
processing centers that we've heard
about in the chaotic and
um you know and and and poor conditions
that we know that you know have been
reported on so really this this
situation here and it's it's another
tragedy and and let's remember this is
almost a year
um since uh since the terrible tragedy
that saw 32 people die in the channel
um and we've been warning for months
that another tragedy is going to happen
unless the government change approach
and start to really constructively think
about how to build back those safe
routes for people to access to come here
safely to reunite with family
anything that the Prime Minister
announced yesterday in his big speech in
the comments that you think will help
very little unfortunately it was more of
the same it was more of the same failed
approach that we've seen over the last
few years this idea that you can create
such a hostile environment for people
who fled war and persecution that they
won't get in these boats has been
categorically shown to fail over the
last few years you know people have got
into a boat in the middle of the night
in the middle of winter in freezing cold
conditions you imagine the desperation
that those people are feeling in order
to do that and we know that creating an
Ever more hostile environment in the UK
will not deter people from doing that
particularly when they have family links
and other community ties here in the UK
and therefore we have to offer them safe
deterrence safe Alternatives sorry
um to be able to come here safely to be
able to claim protection and to be able
to have their Asylum claims processed
fairly and quickly and unfortunately
from the Prime Minister we heard none of
that yesterday it was more promises of
deterrence and hostile environment
there will be those though who will be
watching you listening to this Bethany
who will say yes we understand that
these people have links to the UK they
maybe speak a little English they maybe
have family members here but they are in
a safe country they are in a country
where they are not being persecuted they
have have left the regime that they were
fleeing the final step this step across
the channel does not need to be taken
look there's a few things I'd say to
that firstly most refugees do remain in
countries like France in fact in
countries neighboring to the countries
that they've fled France but you know
twice as many people stop in France
Refugee stop in France as they do and
seek to travel to the UK
um you know every year so um it's you
know we are talking about a small number
of people and those people often have
reasons why they're seeking to come to
the UK such as family and I think most
of us would agree that for you know for
the unaccompanied children that we're
working with in northern France right
now
um you know who have fled their home
countries who have no family back home
and who are fearing for their lives they
should be in the safe loving care of a
family member who is here in the UK and
we should be doing everything we can to
provide them a safe way to get here and
not see them turn to the Smugglers who
will then put them in these dangerous
circumstances that risk their lives in
such tragic circumstances
is there an argument for for flipping
this slightly and saying those loved
ones that they want to be with in the UK
should they not be the ones that that
move that that go to the countries where
their loved ones are and help them uh
and assist them to come across in a
different route rather than them too
knowing that their loved ones are going
on these boats
well I mean
we're talking about refugees here we're
talking about refugees who are on the
Move who fled a home a country and where
they have feared for their lives or have
have have have have
experienced persecution and the the
question we have to ask ourselves is
Britain is who should you know where are
they best place to be protected and to
be in the care of their family and if
they have family here in Britain then
surely we should all acknowledge that
they you know they should be here they
should be in the company of their family
who are here often settled have lives
established who can help them rebuild
their lives
um you know after After experiencing
those those situations back home and and
you know to give you an ex another
example of this we talk a lot about you
know the lack of access to Safe routes
and safe ways for refugees to be able to
come here you think about what's going
on in Iran right now and last this year
sorry we've resettled just nine people
from Iran you know you think and
Iranians make up a high number of those
who are crossing the channel in these
perilous conditions right now you know
we're offering them no other option that
than to get in a boat in order to be
able to come here and claim protection
and and it just shouldn't be the case
and the government could do you know
could take steps tomorrow to
re-establish the safe family reunion
route
um for people who get for refugees in
Europe and to start to build those safe
routes that that would act as a real
alternative deterrent for people having
to get into these dangerous dennies
okay Bethany Gardner Smith good to talk
to you today thank you very much for
joining us on Sky
well earlier scan you spoke to the
former director general of the UK border
Force Tony Smith who spoke on the border
Force operations on the beaches in
France and what conditions would be like
in the channel
we have been working with the French
there was a new agreement quite recently
actually that we would Place border
Force officers in France working in on
operations on the Calais beaches you
know you've you've had footage of what
that environment is like they don't want
to be detected on the beaches because if
they are they will be the the vessels
will be disabled there'll be stock from
Crossing so there's a game of cat and
mouse going on along a very long stretch
of French Beach there between law
enforcement and the Smugglers and so
they will uh you know resort to
Desperate Measures as you say this will
have been dark it will have been cold
the people would have been frightened
but they would have been assured by the
pilot or by somebody behind this look
this is easy don't worry about this it's
not very far just getting here and
everything's going to be okay and that's
what happens so that's why the messaging
is so important to people that if we can
get the message out please do not do not
engage with human Smugglers to get
across the English Channel we have to
stop this we have to stop the boats
because I'm afraid This is highly highly
dangerous as you say you can just
imagine what it must be like for some of
those people that are in that boat in
the dark in those freezing temperatures
where our vessel runs into trouble on
the English Channel we cannot guarantee
your safety we can only do everything in
our power to try and save lives but we
cannot guarantee that because these are
really really difficult conditions and
these are Dangerous Waters and I'm
afraid that message is not played up
enough in this whole debate
foreign
who is in Dungeness for us and Sadia
what is the scene there is there
anything actually happening there
well look we've we've known uh we have
been told that three people are
confirmed to have died and 43 people are
being rescued but this continues to be
an ongoing rescue operation with boat
still out on the water we've seen
helicopters moving around as well the
and it's likely to stay that way at
least until it goes dark and at least
until everyone has been accounted for
that's usually how these things operate
but these are really difficult
conditions for rescue teams to be
operating and we know that the channel
at this time of the year particularly is
a very difficult place to be uh there's
the currents in the channel mean that
you know people can be dispersed very
quickly and very far away what we do
know is that around three this morning a
rescue operation was launched the rnli
Coast Guard vessels from the British
Navy and the
um the French navy were involved in that
in that operation uh it would have been
dark at that time would have been very
difficult to operate in that time but we
know that three people have died and 43
people have been rescued as I say it's
an ongoing operation so we don't know if
those numbers will change we also don't
know who was on board that migrant
vessel that is believed to be a migrant
investor that needed rescuing often many
people would travel without documents
maybe they don't speak English it will
be difficult to communicate and verify
identities straight away but it comes
just a day after the Prime Minister made
that announcement of a new package to
stop these Crossings we've heard time
and time again about how dangerous they
are one thing I think we can be certain
of is just how dangerous that journey is
and just how desperate people must be to
make that journey in the first place but
as I say we don't know the identities of
the people that who are on board and it
does come just over a year after another
vessel got into trouble in these water
that was in November last year when
there were more fatalities around 23 at
that time
Sadie thanks very much thanks for
bringing us the latest down there on the
coaster on the English Channel there not
far from where that boat went down
overnight these are the latest images
that we have we have some images we also
have some moving pictures showing the
helicopter above as well but you could
just see how damaged this boat appears
to be the fact that 43 people were
rescued successfully from it is really
quite astonishing joining me in the
studio Sky correspondents Tamara Cohen
and Amanda acass and Tamara what do you
think the political Fallout from this
will be you said a short while ago that
you actually don't think it will really
move the dial massively in terms of of
what the government does where the
policies change about how we deal with
the issue of illegal migration but also
more specifically these small boats
that's right Rishi CNAC set out a bunch
of measures yesterday which he had been
promising and saying that this was his
top priority as prime minister after the
economy and I imagine that he will say
we're going to hear from him at Prime
Minister's questions at 12 o'clock that
while he deeply regrets Today's tragedy
in which we believe there has been loss
of life and I'm sure he'll no doubt
praise the Emergency Services Swift work
as well and that what he announced
yesterday in terms of deterrence is what
he thinks the right route is to as he
puts it stop the boats now it's been
pointed out a lot including by many of
his own MPS yesterday that while the
measures he's announced sending people
back to Albania which he says is a safe
country
um moving their accommodation in the UK
trying to get the Rwanda scheme going
and giving more money to the National
Crime agency to Target some of the gangs
that all that will make a difference
it's not going to make an enormous
difference and it's not going to happen
overnight there would need to be changes
in legislation which he said he'll look
at next year and that could all get
bogged down and take a long time to
happen so we've had certainly for the
last two or three years excessive Prime
Ministers and Home Secretary saying we
must tackle these Channel boats but not
really managing to come up with anything
that's not just a silver bullet but
that's really making a dent I mean the
numbers just do keep going up and in a
sense it's amazing that since last
November when tragically 30 people died
that we haven't had anything on that
scale since then because people are
attempting these Journeys and as you can
see from those pictures there very
overcrowded perilous conditions in
difficult weather as Amanda was saying
people didn't used to attempt these
Crossings in in the winter it was a
summer saying now it's all year round
and
um you know it's hard to see
um that he's going to suggest any kind
of different approach the approach that
the Charities are calling for more safe
routes what he said yesterday is that
the government has safe routes but they
are only of course for people from
Ukraine from Afghanistan and from Hong
Kong a lot of people from other
countries find it very difficult to make
Asylum claims and that's why and they
say they undertake these difficult
Journeys
thanks very much Tamara and Amanda but
tomorrow just talking about about the
boats themselves you of course have been
out as a reporter in that area you went
out and and on these patrols to see what
was actually happening out there what
are the conditions like for those coming
across well I think sometimes it can
seem a bit deceptive because when the
weather is calm and and the and the sun
is out it seems like it's a very short
stress stretch of of sea 23 miles or so
but of course it is the world's busiest
shipping Lane uh crisscrossed by these
huge um huge tankers varies
um there are many many vessels there who
may not see a tiny boat and I think that
is the key thing that these boats are
really small I think sometimes when you
hear the numbers involved um you know we
know that 43 people have rescued from
this one sometimes you you hear of 60 70
80 people on board these boats but
they're really not designed to hold that
many people most of them are are
designed to hold a couple of dozen
people if that
um and I think when you see them coming
in you can see how many people are
crammed into into this space every inch
of these little rubber dinghies and they
are rubber by and large
um they suffer engine failure they
suffer from punctures and the key thing
I think from when when I was out on one
myself once is that
they are quite low in the water and the
more people you have on them the lower
they get so as soon as you start getting
um choppier Seas or you start getting
big backwash from some of those massive
ships in the shipping lanes you don't
need a huge amount of water slopping
over the edge to start really getting
them at risk of capsizing or tipping or
indeed people being washed overboard and
I think the key thing about this being
something that is operated by criminal
gangs who don't
um that the care for their passengers
isn't their priority people are spending
four to six thousand pounds generally
each it's not per Crossing they make a
lot of money they make more money the
more people they can shove in
um quite often we see Margaret's
arriving not dressed appropriately at
all as we can see from some of these
photos they're often not wearing life
jackets either so you know as soon as
people get cold and wet um you don't
have very long when the conditions are
like this it really is extremely
dangerous and as you see people arriving
their faces when they when they get to
the shore is what is generally an
expression of real relief and people
immediately often being taken for
medical treatment because it's very
common for people to be suffering from
hypothermia which I think given how
difficult that Crossing is
um the deterrent approach people clearly
are very desperate to to make it across
so I think the government's obviously
hoping this message will get through to
people in in in France sleeping Ralph
you've traveled across Europe to try and
make that Crossing I think when the
Rwanda scheme when we thought it was
going to happen there wasn't much
evidence at the time that that message
had got through obviously if it had been
successful maybe it would have done but
obviously it is a complex approach um
and clearly that's why they're also
putting a lot of money into border Force
okay Amanda thanks very much um we've
got some images we can bring you a
warning we're about to show you uh some
footage of the moment of rescue which
viewers may find distressing these are
the images that we've already seen of
the boat being rescued in the channel
are we able to bring you those images
[Music]
thank you
let's bring in the chief executive of
the refugee Council and Solomon who
joins us now
um and we want to ask you about
Solutions I know you're going to say
like the other Charities that we've
spoken to in the last hour that the
solution would be the government
creating more safe routes for these
people to get into our country the
government says that is not in their
plan so what can be done to prevent
people making this terrifying Journey
well let's just first of all pause and
remember who these people are they're
they're men women and children like you
and me but unlike you and me they don't
have a safe place to live they've had to
flee and they've had to do what any
family would do when faced with violence
and bloodshed which is seek safety
somewhere else we saw the images of
people fleeing for their lives in
Ukraine we saw what happened in
Afghanistan when the Taliban stormed to
power we saw people clinging on
airplanes the majority of people coming
across the channel are people who are
fleeing war and violence and bloodshed
the main nationality in the last two
months are Afghans and people know
what's happening in Afghanistan followed
by Iranians and people see the stories
on the news of the persecution and
torture in Iran these are people like
you and me who have had no choice but to
try and reach safety in of the country
and we first and foremost need to
recognize and understand that because
unless we see this
as an issue which is driven by the fact
that there is violence and bloodshed and
persecution across the world we won't be
able to deal with it because desperate
people take Desperate Measures to try
and reach safety and that's the reality
of the situation that we're seeing today
the real tragedy and those appalling
images that viewers just saw of people
desperately trying to reach safety
and in terms of numbers then let's talk
numbers as you say we offered safe
passage to some 150 ukrainians
um how many
numbers how many people do you think the
government should say right you know
we're going to say 10 000 people can
come from around 10 000 people can come
from Syria every year do you and your
head have a sane amount of numbers that
would be a proposal that you think that
the government should offer
well look this isn't a numbers game that
we know from the un's figures that 100
million people uh were displaced uh the
figure of 100 million was reached back
in summer for the numbers displaced
around the world half of those more than
just over half were actually displaced
within countries
and then the vast majority of the
remaining uh flee as refugees to
neighboring countries places like
Lebanon next to Syria that has hundreds
of thousands of refugees Pakistan that
has millions because of what's going on
in Afghanistan a fraction seek asylum in
other parts of the world uh just under
five million about a hundred million and
then a fraction of those will come to
Europe but it's the duty of Western
Nations and that's why they signed the
U.N convention on refugees to respond in
a way that shares responsibility to
provide safety to those that come in
search of it in Europe and in countries
like ours in the UK and that's what we
should do and that's what we've always
sought to do we should give them a fair
hearing there are people across this
country who are making a huge
contribution today who came here fleeing
horrendous atrocities 40 years ago in
Uganda
fleeing the revolution in Iran back in
1979 fleeing the war in Yugoslavia and
more recently fleeing Syria and they
have contributed to this country as
doctors nurses as Architects as
businessmen as business people and
that's what we should focus on how we
ensure we give them a fair hearing so
that those who need protection go on and
contribute as law-abiding citizens in
the UK the problem is of course that
whilst there are those who have
legitimate reasons for wanting to come
here and wanting to settle here there
are those who also don't and we heard
this from the Prime Minister yesterday
in the Commons about the number of
people who are traveling across
illegally from Albania which is still a
safe country and that is the problem
isn't it that for you for for every
legitimate Refugee who has traveled from
a war zone there will be a person who is
coming here as well simply for economic
reasons and who is not fleeing those
kind of persons locations
well let's put it in context
um of course there will be some people
who don't have a well-founded fear of
persecution but the government saying
figures show that more than three
quarters do and more than three quarters
are allowed to stay in the UK as
refugees and if people when they make an
asylum application and the decision is
is made and it's found that they they
shouldn't be allowed to stay as refugees
because they don't have a so-called
genuine case well then we should work
with them to return them with dignity to
the country from which they've come from
in the way that other nations like
Canada have proper voluntary returns
programs we don't do that at the moment
but we also need to ensure that people
when they come here are given a genuine
Fair hearing it's not good enough to
Simply say that it's safe in Albania
because we work with men and children
and women who've come from Albania who
have been trafficked who have been
exploited we work with children who are
are very seriously exploited as a
consequence of the actions of criminal
gangs now that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't simply recognize them as
refugees and turn them away and send
them back to Albania it means that we
should recognize that they're unsafe we
should recognize they're victims of
modern slavery and give them protection
in the UK and if they're not victims of
modern slavery of course we don't accept
them as refugees in this country but the
principle is that we give them a fair
hearing we always see the face behind
the case we always see them as
individual humans who deserve a fair
Hearing in the UK
and for Solomon from the refugee Council
thank you very much
well we spoke earlier with the Dover MP
Natalie elfick and she pointed out that
it was a matter of great urgency that
the boats are stopped from entering the
water from the French side
well I'm very very saddened to hear of
this tragedy in the channel today
um waking up to the news that I fear as
the MP for Dover and deal day after day
lives lost a number saved only 43 saved
only due to the bravery and
professionalism of the Rescue Services
that operate out of Dover and along our
East Kent coast and I have I have to you
know pay tribute to their bravery and
thank them for their rescue mission this
morning in absolutely treacherous wintry
conditions
it must have been a horrific call out at
three o'clock wasn't it
um in terms of what the solution is what
would you like to see the government do
well as I've said now uh time and again
it is a matter of great urgency that the
boats have stopped entering the water
from France uh people are safe in France
this is illegal criminality organized
crime through and through that number of
people crossing now uh very near to 45
000 people that's the result of
industrial illegal immigration by
organized criminal gangs operating on
the shores of France it is urgent that
the Prime Minister who is taking
personal responsibility for this issue
has a summit with president macron and
that action is taken to bring this to an
end before we have further loss of life
in the channel
we spoke to Claire Mosley from the care
for Cali charity just a moment ago she
said one wait waiters get the boats to
not go in the water in France would be
to set up a center in northern France
and offer safe passage to those who who
believe that they have a strong claim
would that not be a solution
unfortunately organizations like care
for Calais are part of the problem not
the solution in dealing with the channel
Crossings care for Kelly is one of the
organizations that's taking legal action
against the government and is not I
think really looking out for those
solutions that would be in the best
interests of people who are in the hands
of these criminal gangs and often also
in crime here in the UK once they are
smuggled in and involved in modern
slavery and we've got to you know really
be clear that those organizations are
blocking the attempts of the government
to be trying to bring an end to the
small boats and crossings it is vital
that they really look at the interests
of people in the hands of criminal gangs
encourage them not to take these
Journeys that are so dangerous and do
result unfortunately and sadly in loss
of life encourage people instead to ask
France for Refugee assistance if they
are in need of it or any other country
before they reach France who is party to
the same Refugee conventions and also to
make it really really clear that the
majority of people who have been
traveling by the small boats arriving in
Britain in recent weeks are albanians
from a safe country and who are not in
need of Refuge or Asylum and it's
absolutely vital that we take action and
bring an end to this and stop these
criminal gangs who are ruthless and do
not care if they are risking lives in
the pursuit of their illegal crime
do you dispute the figures that she
provided as we know that there is a a
particular problem with albanians
traveling across in recent weeks but the
figure that she quoted eighty percent of
those who reached the UK on these small
boats are actually granted Asylum
well we know that our system in the UK
is in need of Reform and the Prime
Minister yesterday set out his
five-point plan for tackling that which
included
as far as you understand it is that is
that a a correct representation of the
facts that 80 of those who have come
across on the small boats are eventually
granted Asylum well we know that once
people are in the UK it is extremely
difficult uh to do anything but for the
majority of people to stay in the UK and
that is why it is such a strong magnet
for people to come in through illegal
routes and try to get to Britain that's
why we have to be very very clear that
illegal immigration is not acceptable
that we do but we do if I can finish but
we do we do have resettlement schemes
that we operate with the United Nations
where we bring people directly from
conflict areas and there are over a
hundred million people displaced around
the globe the right way to deal with
Refugee and Asylum is to make sure that
we have the systems and processes and
support in place to help people we do
that as the Prime Minister said
yesterday more humanitarian visas have
been issued than since the second world
war we are a generous country but this
is about illegal organized crime and if
we want to help people who are in need
of assistance they should not be taking
this incredibly dangerous Crossing we've
seen lives lost again today we've got to
bring it to an end but their point is of
course that you say that they are
illegal but if 80 percent of them are
granted asylum in the UK it shows that
they had a valid case which therefore
means that they are not illegal they had
a valid case for Asylum and they would
argue that because there aren't the safe
routes that they're able to use they've
been forced to take this action
Charities British government had more
safe routes than they wouldn't have to
get on the small boats
there are safe routes of Entry we have
issued as the UK more humanitarian visas
than since the second world war there
are safe passage routes there are
applications for work visas which
hundreds of thousands of people take
there are education visas they're our
family reunion visas that you can apply
in the UK from a room and a computer in
the UK so no family member needs to get
into a boat or be in the hands of
illegal immigration illegal entry to the
UK is a crime it is not the way to come
to the UK the UK does have resettlement
and Asylum programs it does give a
tremendous amount of support around the
globe as well as to people who settle
here in the UK and it's absolutely vital
that those two issues are not confused
to do so just drives up more illegal
immigration we need to tackle this at
source and recognize this for the
illegal activity that it is that our
safe and legal routes to come to the UK
and people must take those they must not
risk their lives or indeed lose their
lives in the wintry sea in the channel
frankly everybody has been expecting
something like this to happen I'd say
honestly I I often think I'm surprised
it doesn't happen more often because so
many of these boats leave from the
beaches and you see them and they are
clearly not seaworthy they're very often
fitted with engines that malfunction
I've seen both leaving beaches and the
engines are sort of spluttering and
dying still within sight of them and
they are often overloaded this boat
appears to have had between 40 and 50
people on board it I can guarantee you
that if you had a choice you would not
be getting on a boat of that type with
49 other people so no there's there's
nothing surprising about this at all
that the similar incident that happened
last year were 31 people died was
probably a culmination of a whole series
of Affairs as is this one nearly exactly
a year later and and frankly it's hard
to think of a more atrocious situation
to find yourself in Charities that we've
been in contact with this morning have
told us that one of them said that they
were in contact with somebody on the
boat and they had the last conversation
they had with them was at 253 in the
morning at that point the channel is a
Inky black it would have been very cold
the waters you've been hearing would
have been freezing and remember this is
the busiest shipping Lane uh in the
world so it's a terrifying journey to
make uh and uh it it is to my mind
remarkable how many of these small boats
actually get across the channel without
going to this uh this sort of peril but
it's a measure of of the desperation and
the desire that people have it's a point
that seems obvious but it's worth making
everybody that you see in a migrant camp
in Calais and Dunkirk and in those areas
is only there for one reason it's not
because they like the Northwest French
Coast it's because they want to get to
Britain and they are going to try to do
so on board a boat it's not a question
at that point of do they fancy it or do
they not they're going to try to get on
a boat and they're going to try and get
across the channel it used to be that at
this time of the year this sort of
cross-channel migration on small boats
sort of faded away and when I say used
to be we're only talking about a
relatively short space of time but but
this year and about last year we've seen
a change and it's almost becoming a year
round uh exercise and of course it's
incredibly perilous to be doing that
journey in this weather
um but also the the conditions if you
exclude the the freezing temperature
yesterday it seems as if conditions were
good for taking a boat across the the
people Smugglers they don't really think
about the temperature they're looking at
the wind and the wind is uh is a factor
here and the wind if it's calm
um seems to have been in their favor I
have to tell you that I mean if this
number is is confirmed that 43 people uh
have been
um have been rescued that would seem to
be a really very very high number at the
fears among many people were of multiple
multiple fatalities French hospitals
have been warned that they would expect
the potential for a significant number
of fatalities if this figure correct is
a 43 rescue that will be
despite the fact that clearly people may
well have died in this that will be a a
really sort of pleasingly high number of
people to have been taken from an
incident of this kind
is the country grinding to a whole prime
minister will your government get a grip
on strikes
I'm sure you guys want to win the
election
well the Prime Minister they're leaving
number 10 Downing Street ahead of taking
questions in the House of Commons very
shortly prime minister's questions is
due to start at 12 o'clock uh we always
preview what is expected to be happening
in the Commons joining me now here in
the studio in Westminster my panel of
MPS for the conservatives Brendan Clark
Smith very good to see you at Labor's
Steve Reed and the snps Alan Smith thank
you all very much Brendan Clark's back
to you first of all in terms of of what
has happened over over the last few
hours the news that we're getting coming
out of of the channel
this is another incident of a number of
people almost losing their lives luckily
it seems just three 43 people rescued
does this change anything with the prime
minister's strategy that he announced
yesterday I don't think so Jay enough I
think this illustrates exactly the
problem that we've got before us and
this is an absolute tragedy it shows
again the criminal gangs and people
Smugglers that are causing this we've
got a clown down on it I'd like to thank
all of the emergency services or the
responders who've actually made this far
less of a tragedy than it actually could
have been I heard that there are three
dead 43 rescued so thank you so much to
the people who've actually got in there
but we've got to stop this from
happening I think the comprehensive set
of measures announced yesterday is going
to be part of doing that
Steve at the labor the campaigners that
we've spoken to this morning have said
that the problem is that whatever the
government announced yesterday it
doesn't create more safe routes the
Prime Minister said he will create more
safe routes but it's much further down
the line is that do you think that is
something the government should be doing
well I mean first off I want to express
my sympathy for the loss of life and
it's shocking and it does show us why
there needs to be a group got on this
issue and the government just hasn't and
you know safe routes would be part of it
but stopping the criminal gangs that are
putting people on these boats and
putting their lives at risk in this way
has to be part of it but we also have to
look at why so many people are coming uh
to our country and one of the reasons is
because the government has simply not
been processing applications so people
come here and they can stay for years
because no one checks they're only they
only process four percent of applicants
every year which is why the hotels are
jam-packed uh of of refugees who are
waiting until permanently for years for
cases to be resolved and that's costing
the British taxpayer six million pounds
a year because frankly the immigration
and Asylum Seeker system is broken and
who broke it it's this government that's
been in power for 12 years now Brenda is
that is that a fair allegation the
system is broken I mean it seems to be
that successful home secretaries have
acknowledged that there are fundamental
issues with the problem with the with
the with the situation they try to fix
it but nothing really seems to change
certainly very difficult yes and I think
I'm not going to disagree what Steve
said about processing applications we
know there's a backlog there the Prime
Minister acknowledged this yesterday and
we're looking at a threefold increase on
how quickly they're going to be
processed now and there's quite an
ambitious Target to actually clear that
by the end of next year but of course
the backlog is only part of the problem
we need to stop them coming over in the
first place and of course once we've
dealt with those claims we need to be
able to remove people especially when
they've come from safe countries that's
why we've done a deal with Albania
that's why we're doing deals with France
that's why we're increasing the number
of Border force staff that are in there
and that's why we're also looking at
cutting of course the cost of these
hotels which we don't want to see we
want to be spending money on public
services we don't want to be spending it
on this but you know did you know that
your your government identified 16 000
people for removal to save countries
over the last two years do you know how
many actually got removed 21 that that
is a government that's frankly given up
on on the immigration system three years
ago pretty Patel told us she had cut the
number of small boats coming across the
channel in half it actually increased
20-fold if they have any ideas they'd
put them into action already they've
completely lost a grip and they don't
know what to do but I'd also put the
point we've had things such as the
nationality and borders Bill we've had
things such as scheme they've been
opposed to every Point see by your party
and of course when we've tried to do
that we've tried to send people back
we've had litigation we've had activists
lawyers jumping in and we've had to lay
the foundations with legislation to get
around that but what we're also doing is
we're making sure we have plans that we
can actually deliver on and that's what
the Prime Minister was saying some have
said that involves eechr and whether you
have to come out of that the prime
minister's actually done something that
I think we can achieve without doing
that and that's the point he was making
yesterday yes it's a problem but we're
dealing with it others they're trying to
block it let's bring another Smith from
the SNP what's your view on on this I
mean obviously you look at the borders
and the coast of Kent it feels a long
way from from people you know thinking
about politics in Aberdeen but but but
what's the s P's view well no it feels
very close to people in Aberdeen the
people of Scotland are horrified with
what's happening on the UK government's
watch and this this point scoring isn't
going to solve anything no this is not a
unique problem to the UK I was a member
of the European Parliament for 16 years
we're seeing Dreadful situations in the
Aegean in the Mediterranean as well and
what we need to do is to look further
Upstream as to why we can all agree that
that criminal gangs are Dreadful people
who need to be cracked down on but the
root cause of this is that there are
desperate people fleeing turmoil and War
in their own countries trying to get
here for sanctuary and for safety and
there are not sufficient routes to get
them there and I would degree I think
we'd all agree the UK Asylum processing
system has been massively grossly
underfunded as a matter of deliberate
government policy and they're now trying
to claim that that needs a further
Crackdown on the boats obviously people
risking their lives at Sea is a dreadful
Dreadful situation but it's a sign of
failure that we need to look at in the
totality of it I would suggest we need
more European cooperation we need safer
routes to get people from policies of
harm to places of sanctuary we're not
seeing that at the moment and tackling
the symptoms on a political blame game
is just not going to cut it in terms of
safer routes Brandon the Prime Minister
uh did say there would be some but he's
he said you know once we've got a grip
on the situation which suggests not
imminently at least and that seems to be
the one thing that that all of the
refugee Charities and the charges that
work with those trying to come across in
this way agree on that that they argue
that 80 of those people who are on these
boats when their Asylum claims are
actually processed in the UK are granted
Asylum which suggests they have a
legitimate grounds for Asylum they are
people who would be applying through
safe routes if they existed they say
well I'd say the secrets do exist today
if existed for Ukraine for Syria for
Afghanistan of course for Hong Kong as
well so we have had these safe routes
there but of course those are only for
specific countries that we pick there
are lots of people from lots of other
countries aren't there well it's yeah
it's about European approach as well and
it's about looking with other countries
and taking our fair share which I
believe we've also done but of course
many are also economic migrants now if
you are an economic migrant of course
there are many legal routes for that if
you've got the skills and qualifications
that you can bring to this country I've
done it before as an immigrant when I've
been abroad as well so there are the
paths there to do it but I think what
you're looking at is menu we're looking
at cheating the system at the moment
there's widespread criminality you look
at the number of men that are on these
boats you look at a third of the people
coming over from Albania or a safe
country I think there are people really
they they want a a fair immigration
system a humanitarian system but what
they don't want to see is to be cheated
it's all about fairness chain and we
really are committed to that and that's
of our point isn't it Steve that a lot
of people will look at these images and
we'll look at previous images in the
past and say you know these these are
not all people who are fleeing from
conflict zones why should we take things
yeah that's why labor has been it makes
people very angry it makes all of us
very angry and you know what what
Labor's been calling for for a long time
now is to properly resource the
immigration and Border staff so that we
can process these applications faster
and then remove those who do not have a
right to come here as Asylum Seekers but
the government's done neither there's a
a big backlog because they're not
processing and then for the few they do
process they don't remove so the
government's got it wrong what Labor's
calling for is much closer cooperation
with the French authorities the Belgian
authorities and europol so they can
tackle its source the people Smugglers
who are responsible for bringing so many
of these individuals to color it's no
accident that all the small boats you
see are exactly the same there are
Smuggler gangs behind that but the
government hasn't cracked down on that
either so pretty much wherever you look
in the whole chain that leads to this
crisis the government has been negligent
very briefly Alan Smith the SMP would
you like to see more migrants being
taken up to Scotland do you think
there's more space there are more homes
there are more vacancies up there people
would welcome having more migrants there
I'm very proud of the fact that Scotland
has per capita taken far more than our
first year and I would pick up on the
point that the UK is taking its fair
share look at the European statistics
the UK has taken nothing like its fair
share particularly from Ukraine look at
how many people Ireland has given Safe
Haven to and given Sanctuary to now
there's a distinction between Asylum and
immigration and I do accept that some
folks crossing the channel are economic
migrants but that's why the system to
process them needs to be better resource
than it is the idea that this is all
about criminal gangs needing cracked
down on is just to to really miss the
point and what we do need is a much
wider discussion about this
okay uh
it doesn't always have a uh a musical a
musical
news bear has arrived
we've been talking about this this
Dreadful situation the Channel all
morning
um but the Prime Minister prime
minister's questions obviously the last
one before Christmas do you do you think
that this will dominate or do you think
actually he will want to focus on on
what he was focus on in here look I
think they will mention it at the top of
pmqs but there is a Home Secretary
statement of the prime minister's
questions on this case unfolding in the
channel what's going on we we think that
three people have died and we think that
at the moment 43 people have been
potentially taken out of the channel
that's the latest information we have
from our reporters who are covering that
but but what will kill star would go on
I think this week he will tackle strikes
head-on and he will criticize the
government for uh what he will say is in
action in trying to resolve pay disputes
I think that label will go quite
strongly on the narcissist strike
tomorrow one on the 15th it's one on the
21st at once all same to me previously
it's felt like this is chaos now this
week it's genuinely terrifying is what
one of my labor sources are telling me
in terms of the nurse's strike we got
that letter last night Jane that was
from Dame Kelly who's the head of Cancer
Care for the NHS England
asking nurses to have a national
delegation that means to effectively
protect emergency and Urgent Cancer Care
worries about patient Ops being delayed
and what does that mean for people's
longevity or life-saving treatment
there's also a letter in the times today
from some leading nurses saying that
they're also concerned about patient
care and it's a really uneasy time isn't
it nurses have never gone on strike and
tomorrow they're set to go on strike and
what's the knock-on effect for people
need an acute pair or people falling
very ill will they get the treatment
they need and I think that that is where
kirstma will go for the government and
go for Russia sunak I guess the question
is how Rishi sunak responds to that in
the past he has accused kirst armor of
being in the pocket of the unions and
failing to stand up for them themselves
but I think labor have a view that the
government's refusal if you like to to
reopen pay negotiations with nurses this
week is something that he can really
attack the government on and what about
the economy inflation dropped slightly
today inflation's dropped slightly look
we thought that October would be the
peak it's falling back to I think 10.7
from 11.1 in October look we expect
inflation to dip back to two percent
towards the end of the year according to
Independent forecasts but of course in
the meantime people are really
struggling with the cost of living
struggling to make ends meet and feeling
really the sharp end of that cost of
living crisis and that inflation is
still huge for people when their wages
are going up three to percent in the
public sector and inflation's running at
10.7 percent well it is 12 o'clock
you're watching Sky News uh prime
minister's questions is just about to
begin we think the prime minister is
going to take to his feet any minute now
I can generally say to the lady that the
atmosphere in the relationships between
the European Union and the United
Kingdom government have changed
dramatically in in recent weeks and
months and that is the basis for all
good things
that completes those questions before we
come to prime minister's questions I
would like to point out the British sign
language interpretation of proceedings
available to watch on Parliament live TV
we start with questions to prime
minister John Stevenson yeah number one
Mr Speaker prime minister
Mr Speaker I'm sure the whole house will
share my sorrow at the capsizing of a
small boat in the channel in the early
hours of this morning and the tragic
loss of human life our hearts go out to
all those affected and our tributes to
those involved in the extensive rescue
operation Mr Speaker
then I had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others in addition to my
duties in this house including the visit
of his majesty the king I shall have
further such meetings later today John
Stevens thank you Mr Speaker prime
minister uh three and a half hour
Journey takes six hours a straight
Journey ends up with two changes and a
diversion a train is canceled at short
notice this has become the experience of
a West Coast rail passenger if Avanti do
not get their act together will the
government cancel their franchise
very popular question
Mr Speaker I thank my honorable friend
for raising this and I share the
frustration that this is causing to many
of his and other communities our
priority immediately is to support the
restoration of services before then
making any long-term decisions on the
operation of the West Coast franchise
but we will be closely monitoring
Avanti's rollout of its recovery plan
and holding them account for delivering
for passengers they did the opposition
kill Starman
uh thank you Mr Speaker can I join the
Prime Minister our prayers go out to
those who capsized in the freezing
Waters of the channel last night it's a
reminder that the criminal gangs running
those routes put the lives of the
desperate at risk and profit from their
misery they must be broken up and
brought to Justice
Mr Speaker tomorrow will be the first
ever Nationwide nurses strike
all the primaries touched to do to stop
that is to open the door and discuss pay
with them if he did the whole country
would Breathe the sight of relief
why won't he
prime minister Mr Speaker we have
consistently spoken to all the unions
involved in all the pay disputes that
there are but I am I am glad he's raised
our nurses because they do do incredible
work and it's worth putting on record
it's worth putting on record what
exactly we have done for our nurses last
year last year when the rest last year
when everyone else in the public sector
had a public sector pay freeze the
nurses received a three percent pay rise
when the LCN asked for more in-work
training we gave every nurse and midwife
a 1 000 pound training budget
when they asked for nurses bursaries we
made sure that every nursing student
received a 5 000 pound Grant that's
because we do work constructively and we
will continue to back our nurses
Mr Speaker nurses going on strike is a
badge of Shame for this government
instead of showing leadership he's
playing games with people's health
and there is a human cost Alex from
Chester has been waiting for a
gallbladder operation for nearly six
months he's in so much pain he's been
off school since then his operation has
already been canceled twice
his mum who I spoke to this morning is
worried sick
when she heard that strikes could be
called off she was massively relieved
she's desperate for the prime minister
to resolve this all he needs to do is
simply meet the nurses Alex's mum is
listening to this she doesn't want to
hear him blaming everybody else she
doesn't want his usual ducking of the
question she's tuned in now because she
wants him to explain what is he going to
do to resolve the nursing Strife
Mr Speaker it's not just Alex there are
millions of others across this country
millions of others millions of others
who will have their health care
disrupted because of the strike Now The
Honorable gentleman says to get round
the table but we all know what that
means Mr Speaker that is just simply a
political formula for avoiding taking a
position on this issue
If he if he thinks if he thinks the
strikes are wrong he should say so
[Applause]
that's right
right that pay demands of 19 are met
then he should say so
what what's weak Mr Speaker is he's not
strong enough to stand up to the union
[Applause]
we know it's Christmas but the party's
not started yet come on
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
in 12 hours time there's a nurse's
strike all he needs to do is meet the
nurses his inaction speaks volumes as
ever with this prime minister it's Tory
politics first patient second
we've never seen a nurse's strike like
this before
they've been forced into it because the
government has broken the health system
asked anyone in the NHS they will
to have enough
[Music]
thousand vacancies and there's an
obvious solution scrap the non-dom
status and use the money to bring
through the next generation of doctors
and nurses that's what labor would do
why hasn't he got the guts to do it
Mr Speaker we're already investing
billions more in the NHS we're already
hiring thousands more doctors and nurses
but he asked he asked he asked about
backlog he asks about backlogs in the
waiting times in the NHS and yes what he
always fails to acknowledge is the
impact that kovid did Mr Speaker how
that's why we're facing pressures but we
do have a plan not just more money not
just more doctors and nurses new
diagnostic Centers carrying out millions
of checks and scans new surgical hubs
delivering more elective surgery but if
if we'd listened to him Mr Speaker the
backlog would still be growing and
that's because we'd still be in lockdown
well as usual Mr Speaker he tries to
blame everyone else his Department his
Department commissioned a report into
the NHS which reported on Monday that
report said we've had 10 years of
managed decline it was not covered
responsibility is sitting right there
and the reason he can't choose nurses
over non-doms is because he's too weak
to stand up for tax avoiders
for 12 years they haven't trained enough
doctors and nurses so we have the Absurd
situation of the NHS spending billions
on agency workers to fill the Gap why
should the country have to put up with
money that should be spent treating
patients being wasted plugging gaps
instead
Mr Speaker Let Me Tell The Honorable
gentleman what we are doing we are
actually listening to the independent
pay review bodies
they want to undermine them we've
offered a fair pay deal they can't even
decide on a number amongst themselves
we're actually protecting the public
they're protecting their pay masters Mr
Speaker
for working people in this country
for working people in this country it's
Labor's Nightmare Before Christmas
[Applause]
titling that is on waiting list or those
that can't afford to pay for a next day
GP appointment
12 years of Tory failure winter has
arrived for our public services and
we've got a prime minister who has
curled up in a ball and gone into
hibernation
who wants these strikes called off then
surely the whole country is entitled to
ask what is the point of him and what is
the point of the government he's
supposed to be leading
prime minister well
Mr Speaker he talked about the covert
not having impact ambulance waiting
times for category one category one
ambulance waiting times in February of
2020 were actually completely On Target
Mr Speaker cobit has has an impact and
that's why that's why that's why as as
the chief executive of the NHS has
acknowledged this government is serious
about its commitment to prioritize the
NHS but Mr Speaker let's just have a
look at the NHS in labor run Wales shall
we
foreign
the worst a e times in the country Mr
Speaker
but under the last Labor government we
had Fair pay for nurses and no strikes
so when I won't be taking lectures from
him about that
[Applause]
order order Mr Bowie you promised to
behave don't give me a Christmas present
you want one come on
Mr Speaker this is our final pmqs of the
year so I hope you will pop oh really I
hope you will
uh Mr Speaker what I was going to say
was I hope you will pass on all of our
thanks at least on this side to all
those who kept our house and our
democracy working and I want to finish
this year thinking about our friends in
Ukraine as a result of Putin's barbaric
assault on their freedom Millions will
spend Christmas in Sub-Zero temperatures
without heating electricity or hot water
their suffering is unimaginable but
their bravery is awe-inspiring
so will the Prime Minister join me in
saying that whatever other difficulties
and disagreements we have across this
dispatch box
we are and will remain United in our
unwavering support for Ukraine's Freedom
its Liberty and its victory
well Mr Speaker can I join with the
honorable gentleman in thanking and
paying tribute to all the staff of the
house for the Fantastic work that they
do to support all of us and I appreciate
his comments on Ukraine it's been a
point of incredible Unity across this
house and indeed the country something
that we can all be proud of in our
country that we have stood behind
Ukraine at its hour of need and as I
said yesterday this Christmas many
families will be laying an extra place
at their Christmas table and that speaks
to the generosity and compassion of our
nation and long may that continue
Angela Richards thank you Mr Speaker the
A3 connects London to Portsmouth through
Guildford and I was delighted to see the
new solent Freeport announced last week
which will increase traffic flows as the
A3 Narrows through Guildford as a sadly
the most polluted Road in the Strategic
Road Network short-term sticking
plasters like putting up nine meter high
air pollution barriers that will
entrench divisions in Guildford is not
acceptable to me or my constituents does
my right honorable friend agree with me
that it is time to think big it is time
to think long term and it is time to
Tunnel the A3 under Guilford Frank
okay I thank my uh I thank my honorable
friend for the question I know this is
an issue that she is long championed I
am told that National highways are
developing a range of different
possibilities and solutions for the A3
through Guildford and I know the
department for transport will consider
the case as it plans its future
infrastructure Investments SMP leader
Stephen Flynn
yeah I wish to join with the Prime
Minister and the leader of opposition
and extending my party's thoughts to all
of those involved in the terrible
tragedy in the channel this morning Mr
Speaker thanks to positive and proactive
negotiations between the Scottish
government and unite and Unison Health
unions our pay settlement has been
reached in strike action averted by
Stark contrasts the UK Health secretary
appears completely unwilling to
negotiate with unions on pay and strike
action is very much still on the table
so may I ask the Prime Minister when
will he see the error of his ways and
follow the Scottish government's lead
my little stuff well Mr Speaker I'm glad
the UK government was able to provide
one and a half billion pounds an extra
to the Scottish government for public
that the health secretary in other
ministers have engaged fully not just
with the unions but with an independent
pay setting process which takes the
politics out of the process and ensures
that we can meet those independent
requirements with a fair pay deal
Stephen Flynn Mr Speaker let's be clear
those words will ring Hollow in the ears
of those people who unlike the Prime
Minister canning up into waitrose for
their shopping nor indeed even turn on
the key time at this moment in time and
that's particularly true for people in
Scotland because as we know average
energy bills in Scotland are not
anticipated to be 2 500 pounds per year
they're expected to be 3 300 pounds per
year people are genuinely terrified and
that's despite the fact that Scotland
produces six times more gas than we
consume with some 80 of our electricity
coming from low carbon sources Decades
of failed UK energy and Regulatory
policy coming
is it not the case that Scotland has the
energy we just need the power
[Applause]
yeah well Mr Speaker I'm glad the
honorable gentleman raised the question
of energy support and it's because of
the actions of this government that we
are providing every household in this
country with around 900 pounds of
support with their energy bills this
winter 55 billion pounds worth of
support and on top of that next year
there will be extra cost of living
payments worth up to 1 200 pounds for
the most vulnerable whether that's those
or means-tested benefits pensioners or
indeed disabled this is a government
that will always look after the most
vulnerable in our society
thank you Mr Speaker as my right
honorable friend will know the mayor of
London despite objections has decided to
expand the Euless Zone across all London
boroughs which will massively impact my
constituents and those who share a
border with London will he therefore
urgently speak to the transport
secretary and encourage him to use the
powers at his disposal to reverse this
disastrous decision prime minister or my
uh honorable friend will know that
transport in London is devolved to the
labor mayor of London but
uh but by the leader of the opposition
is choosing not to listen to the public
the zone is being expanded against the
overwhelming views of residents and
businesses and I've urgently consider
them there and the gentleman opposite to
be on the side of hard-working londoners
hey David can I shoot myself from my
party with the comments made by others
on the tragedy in the channel our
thoughts and prayers are with the
family's victims
Mr Speaker 40 of cancer patients now ate
more than two months for treatment
after an urgent referral from a GP
that's the highest proportion on record
and way above the government's own
cancer awaiting Target
I lost both my parents to cancer as a
child
and so like many people across the
country and in this house
I know the devastating impact of
treatment delays on cancer patients and
their families
so I'd like to ask the Prime Minister
two questions
first can you give a cast iron guarantee
that the Dreadful cancer backlog won't
get any worse
and second when will the government meet
his own counter Target
prime minister
Mr Speaker I'm very sorry to hear about
the right armor gentleman's parents
indeed I'm sure many of us across this
house have been been our families have
been tragically affected by what cancer
does and he's right to raise the
importance of meeting our targets and
what I am able to tell him is we
actually are experiencing very high
numbers of cancer referrals following
the pandemic he'll be aware of that but
thanks to the brilliant work of our NHS
staff cancer treatment rates in the most
recent month for which we have data are
now back at pre-pandemic levels with a
plan for them to increase further and
recently the NHS also announced plans to
fast-track patients direct to cancer
tests rather than have to wait for
specialist consultation first these
measures will make a difference and I
look forward to updating on them in the
New Year Terry Robinson thank you Mr
Speaker with the closure of the last
bank in Cheadle yet another of my local
communities has been left totally bereft
over High Street banking service so I
was pleased when I heard the
announcement that cheetah was to get a
banking hub
unfortunately my delight was short-lived
when on closer inspection I saw the
Jewish Cheadle Staffordshire
well sorry main pleas for the other
Cheadle would my right honorable friend
agree with me that my constituents also
lead to access to cash and banking
facilities to protect businesses and
support our High Street and will he
support our local pause for post office
banking hubs prime minister my honorable
friend is a fantastic Champion for
Cheadle in Greater Manchester she will
she will know that the financial
services and markets bill will establish
a legislative framework for protecting
access to cash and alongside this firms
are already working to provide shared
services as she mentioned like bank
cards but what I would encourage
vulnerable friend to do is to contact
link which and which can undertake an
independent assessment of a community's
cash access needs and determine if
shared facilities are appropriate maybe
in Hamilton
Mr Speaker my constituent Sharon has an
11 year old daughter who suffers from
eating disorders and severe anorexia she
was forced to spend a year in hospital
in Sheffield 40 miles away because there
were no beds in Leeds for children with
those Eating Disorders this Mr Speaker
is completely unacceptable so will the
Prime Minister now commit to ensuring
that NHS mental health provision for
young people is dramatically improved so
that no other family has to ever again
endure similar trauma
well first of all can I say to Sharon
and her family I'm sorry about what
she's experienced The Honorable
gentleman makes an excellent point
mental health funding as he knows is
increasing so we ensure parity of
service he's also right to raise the
issue of Eating Disorders it's something
that provision is currently expanding
for I think 2 000 more children uh were
given the treatment that and the advice
and support they needed last year and
there are plans to go further because
it's an issue that needs tackling Jason
would come thank you Mr Speaker a police
Constable Nicola Hughes and PC Fiona
bone were savagely murdered in
Manchester whilst on duty a decade ago
Nicholas dad Brynn is my constituent he
lives in Marsden he was in Parliament
again last week continuing his campaign
for emergency service workers and police
officers who die whilst on duty to be
awarded the Elizabeth medal poster
seriously does my right honorable friend
agree with me and Bryn that now is the
time to commemorate and honor our brave
police officers and emergency service
workers who make the ultimate sacrifice
by awarding posthumously the Elizabeth
medal prime minister I thank my
honorable friend for his question and I
thank his constituent Brynn for his
campaigning every life loss in the line
of duty is a tragedy and we remember the
lives and service of PC's Nichola Hughes
and Fiona bone we are determined Mr
Speaker to ensure that sacrifice the
police officers and other Public Service
officers make is recognized and we are
carefully considering the best and most
appropriate ways to do this Kirsty
Blackman
across these islands people are
suffering because of the woefully
inadequate policies of this UK Tory
government they've crashed the economy
left millions in fear of the cold this
winter and our stoking division or we're
striking workers rather than negotiating
fear pay deals why is it that the
orderly people that can rely on this
prime minister are questionable PPE
suppliers of the House of Lords bankers
and former Prime Ministers getting
taxpayer-funded handouts to defend their
partying through covet
five minutes
Mr Speaker the the only people stoking
division in our United Kingdom are the
party opposite
12 sir I Minister
Mr Speaker our priorities are growth
investing in public services and giving
businesses the confidence they need to
invest I look forward to discussing this
with the mayor of the West Midlands
vital Fabrica Mr Speaker when my right
vulnerable friend the Prime Minister
recently visited the national Memorial
Arboretum he was slightly late but I
don't blame him because he had to come
by Road
now my friend the mayor of the West
Midlands is supporting an extension of
the Cross City Line from Birmingham
using an existing freight line to make
it into a rail service to the National
Memorial Arboretum and Beyond so may I
ask my right honorable friend will he
revisit the national Memorial Arboretum
again see the Armed Forces Memorial and
also come to Litchfield and see why we
need a Leisure Center
well
I I'd be uh I'd be delighted to come and
visit the National Memorial Arboretum
again see my friend and the Fantastic
mayor of the West Midlands Andy Street
to discuss his plans to drive growth and
opportunity in the region
thank you thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker it is now well over three years
since the conservatives promised the end
no fault evictions Enfield has the
highest rate of section 21 evictions in
London 30 families in my constituency
and the last month alone were made
homeless as a result of section 21. I
have families sat in my office trying to
keep warm as we try to find them
emergency accommodation will the Prime
Minister scrap this shameful legislation
if so when
well Mr Speaker The Honorable lady will
know that we have announced plans to do
that and we await parliamentary time but
it's not but it's not the only thing we
are doing uh to protect renters uh Mr
Speaker we have passed legislation
already to protect tenants from rip-off
fees and we've kept holding deposits
because we want to make sure that
renters do have the protections that
they require and they have their decent
homes to rent
them thank you Mr Speaker small modular
reactors are a hugely important part of
our future energy and this conservative
government realized that when it awarded
Rolls-Royce nuclear section based in my
constituency a grant 210 pounds for
development but there's still no Clarity
or plan from moving from development to
deployment will the Prime Minister come
with me to meet Rolls-Royce to discuss
how to move things forward and ensure
the UK benefits from this exciting
opportunity
all my uh my honorable firm makes an
excellent point I'm delighted that
government has awarded 210 million
pounds to Rolls-Royce SMR last year for
research and development this does have
the potential to benefit the UK and
support our energy security and climate
goals I look forward to getting updates
and for working with my honorable friend
to see this fantastic new technology
come to life
[Applause]
when my constituent who has dementia was
taken ill recently it took three hours
for an ambulance to arrive he then spent
10 hours in the back of an ambulance
outside a e cueing to get in and the
doctor said to him I'm so sorry we're
treating you out of the back of a truck
but as we've heard the king's fund has
said that the government has presided
over a decade of neglect of managed
decline in the NHS so isn't it the Prime
Minister not that Doctor Who should be
apologizing
[Applause]
Mr Speaker that same Kings fund report
also acknowledged that there was 40 more
funding going into the NHS under this
conservative government but we do need
to make sure that that funding makes a
difference that's why this winter half a
billion pounds is being deployed to move
people out of hospital beds into social
care to speed up those discharges
specifically so that ambulances won't be
queuing as much as they currently are
and that money is already making a
difference on the ground
today thank you Mr Speaker to the
community in kingshurst which I
represent has suffered an unimaginable
tragedy earlier this week when four
children fell through the ice at Babson
Lake sadly three of the children did not
survive and one a six-year-old is
fighting for his life they and their
their families are all in my thoughts
and prayers well my right honorable
friend paid tribute to the community in
Kingston which has come together and is
supporting each other to get through
this tragedy and will you recognize the
heroic efforts of the emergency services
including the police officer who used
his bare hands to try and break through
the ice and then jumped in the water
with fire service Personnel without the
PPE risking their own life to save the
young children
Minister I thank my honorable friend and
can I send my condolences to the family
and friends of all of those who lost
their lives I also join him in paying
tribute to our emergency services for as
he said they're incredibly selfless
actions this whole event has completely
shocked the local community and I know
that my honorable friend will continue
to do all he can to support his
constituents at this difficult time Dave
Angelo Regal
Mr Speaker this year the Tory party has
given us five education secretaries four
chancellors three prime ministers two
leadership
all right
and me and Mr Speaker The Partridge just
had to sell the pear tree to pay the gas
[Laughter]
so uh Mr Speaker isn't it the case that
after a year of Tory chaos incompetence
and self-indulgence the best Christmas
present the Prime Minister could give to
the British people is a general
thank you
so Mr Speaker when it
let's see again they're happier with
that than before Mr Speaker but all I'd
say all I'd say when it comes to what
the British people need this Christmas
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker in order to ease
the disruption on their lives the best
thing that the party opposite could do
is tell their union bosses to call off
these damaging strikes
thank you Mr Speaker after the second
world war Winston Churchill sent British
conservative lawyers to help to draft
the European convention on human rights
and that's something that we can be
proud of in this country but in an age
of mass migration the echr is now
limiting our ability to control our
borders
so in light of the tragedy in the
channel this morning
does the Prime Minister agree he should
do as Churchill did draft a new
framework for refugees and human rights
including legal groups but one way or
another and if necessary alone we must
be prepared to leave the echr
[Music]
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker as I told the house yesterday
our new legislation will deliver a
system whereby a person who comes here
illegally will have no right to stay and
will be removed to their own country or
a safe Third Country alternative that is
the system that the British people want
to see that's a system that we will
deliver and I look forward to hearing
whether the party opposite will support
it so
thank you Mr Speaker as temperatures are
plummeting and the cost of living crisis
is deepening ordinary families are
facing a dickensian nightmare across the
country this Christmas mortgage bills
are soaring household repossessions are
up and nearly half a million tenants
face a threat of eviction after falling
behind on their rent too many people are
worrying about where they and their
children will wake up on Christmas
morning so will the Prime Minister agree
to a temporary ban over the festive
period on repossessions and evictions so
that nobody has to live in fear of
losing their home this Christmas
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we provide a range of support
to both homeowners and tenants who are
in difficulty already but the most
important thing we are doing to
financially support them through the
winter is by providing almost 900 pounds
of support with their energy bills on
top of all the additional support for
those who are most vulnerable including
pensioners that demonstrates the actions
of this government to help the country
get through what we acknowledge is a
challenging time Stephen Krell
tomorrow Mr Speaker at 9 30 you'll lead
this house in a one-minute silence to
Mark 80 years since the British
government recognized that the Holocaust
was taking place in Nazi occupied Europe
as we come together to mark that moment
will the Prime Minister join me in
praising the Holocaust educational trust
and the extraordinary survivors who
continue to do amazing work ensuring
that the Next Generation understand and
learn the lessons from the past
Mr Speaker 80 years ago Parliament
listened in stunned silence as the truth
of the Holocaust was spoken in this
house for the very first time so it's
absolutely right that you Mr Speaker
lead a moment of silence in which we
will stand together to remember and
reaffirm that truth I joined my
honorable friend in paying tribute to
the work of the Holy forced educational
trust and it could not be more fitting
than Britain's Holocaust Memorial and
learning center should be built right
next door to here to Parliament we must
never forget the Holocaust and we would
Stamp Out anti-Semitism and Prejudice in
all its forms wherever we find it Chris
Evans thank you Mr Speaker County
Borough Council recently announced a
three million pound cost of living
hardship fund to help those most in need
in Islam and across our County Borough
does the Prime Minister think it's right
that local authorities are forced to
cover the costs of 12 Years of economic
mismanagement by this Tory government
Mr Speaker what the honorable gentleman
fails to acknowledge is that because of
the actions of this UK government not
only are we supporting people in Wales
and across the United Kingdom with help
with our energy bills we've also
provided 1.2 billion pounds of extra
funding for the Welsh government to use
to give to local authorities to support
their constituents and he would do well
to acknowledge the benefits of the
United Kingdom and the actions of the UK
government
we have a record 4 000 newly qualified
doctors training to be GPS which is
really excellent but we do have an issue
with retention which is made even worse
in areas like mine which have extremely
high housing growth as a son of a GP
what will the Prime Minister do to fix
this prime minister well um Mr Speaker I
know this is an issue that my honorable
friend has talked in Champion for a long
term and his right to do so we do have
record numbers of GPS in training at the
moment we're also making sure that we
support Prime repair appointments and
Primary Care access and I know that my
normal friendly Health secretary and
Chancellor are looking at how best we
can increase retention particularly with
regard to pensions and I look forward to
getting his suggestions final question
Wendy Chamberlain thank you Mr Speaker
immigrant response from the DWP it was
confirmed to me that an unpaid cater
earning more than 132 pounds a week in
their job is classed as being in gainful
employment and as a result loses their
carers allowance of 69.70 a week now
caring doesn't stop it never stops so
can the Prime Minister explain to me the
rationale of this decision given that we
are trying to get economically and
active people back into work and
secondly can explain why it's his
government's position that 132 pounds a
week is enough for people to live on
Mr Speaker can I first start by paying
tribute to those up and down the country
who give up so much of their time to
care for others and I'm actually
delighted that the government is
supporting the members bill which will
give a week of Highly flexible paid
leave to unemployed carers I think is
the right thing to do and I'm grateful
that The Honorable lady is taking it
Forward carers allowance is a means
tested benefit as part of many other
benefits that are available to support
people and as I've said right now there
are significant support in place for
people through Christmas with their
energy bills complete prime minister's
questions just let the house clear
well that is they're the end of prime
minister's questions the nurses strikes
and the various strikes that are
affecting the country a large thrust of
many of the questions there just before
we bring you analysis of what happened
there with our political editor Beth
Rigby let's just bring you the latest
from what's happened out in the English
Channel it has now been confirmed that
four people have died after a migrant
boat capsized in that in the English
Channel the small boat that gone into
difficulty crossing the channel 43
people they're rescued by border force
and are nli
that well let's bring in our political
editor Beth Rigby to reflect on what did
happen there during prime minister's
questions and all of the parties
referred to what what's happened this
morning in the channel
um it's obviously been a big news story
but very quickly turned on to the wider
implications of the strikes that are
affecting the whole country yeah and
it's difficult territory this for Rishi
suno for the Prime Minister I mean
kirstama opening up on the nurses strike
actually not talking about all the other
strikes going on but particularly on the
nurse's decision to strike tomorrow and
he said why won't you open the door and
discussions we're going to cut in
because the home secretaries make the
statement about what happened to make a
statement about an incident in the
channel this morning
this is an ongoing search and rescue
incident but I can confirm that at the
time of making this statement tragically
there have been four fatalities
it would be an appropriate Mr Speaker
for me to go into further detail at this
time
there is a multi-agency response to this
terrible tragedy
his Majesty's Coast Guard the rnli South
East Coast Ambulance the ministry of
Defense police and Border Force together
with French vessels and a commercial
fishing vessels and contractors at
Western jet fall have responded this
morning Mr Speaker I have spoken to
borderforth officials based at Dover
manston and involved in the search and
rescue effort I've also spoken to my
French counterpart the interior Minister
Gerald Domin
a full statement will be provided to the
house in due course once the facts have
been fully established and the necessary
investigative work completed
I know that everyone in this house and
across the country will join me in
expressing our profound sadness and
deepest sympathies for everyone affected
by this terrible event
I know that they will also join me in
offering our profound gratitude to those
working on the search and rescue
operation
that very much includes those who are
responding to The Incident Commander Dan
omahani and his team are working
tirelessly with military colleagues and
other partners day in and day out
to try to prevent this type of tragedy
they are undertaking immensely difficult
work and we should all be extremely
grateful to them
Mr Speaker these are the days that we
dread
crossing the channel
in unseaworthy vessels is a lethally
dangerous endeavor
it's reason above all that we are
working so hard to destroy the business
model of the people Smugglers evil
organized criminals who treat human
beings as cargo
as the Prime Minister told the house
only yesterday
it is not cruel or unkind to want to
break the Stranglehold of the criminal
gangs who trade in human misery and who
exploit our system and our laws
he was right
this morning's tragedy
like the loss of 27 people on One
November Day last year
is the most sobering reminder possible
of why we have to end these Crossings
we recently agreed the largest ever
small boats deal with France with more
boots on the ground patrolling their
beaches UK and French officers working
together in both countries
Calais group of northern European
nations Works to disrupt trafficking and
smuggling all along the migration route
and has set an ambition for a UK eu-wide
agreement on migration
and since 2015 we have welcomed 450
000 people here from all across the
world via safe and legal routes making
these dangerous Crossings totally
unnecessary
but it was evident
that we had to go much further which is
why the Prime Minister announced a new
package yesterday
it includes a new permanent unified
small boats operational command bringing
together the military civilian
capabilities and the National Crime
agency
it will coordinate intelligence
interception processing and enforcement
using advanced technology including
drones
we are adding
more than 700 new staff and doubling the
funding for the NCA to tackle organized
immigration crime in Europe
the Prime Minister announced yesterday a
new agreement with Albania
for the first time border Force officers
will be embedded in Tirana airport
helping to disrupt organized crime
groups and people Smugglers risking
people's lives unnecessarily
and early next year we will introduce
new legislation to make it unambiguously
clear that if some that if someone comes
to the UK illegally they should not be
able to remain here
instead they can expect to be detained
and swiftly returned either to their
home country or to a safe country where
they claim whether where they claim for
Asylum will be considered
late or spurious claims and appeals will
not be possible and once someone has
been removed they will have no right to
re-entry settlement or citizenship
this will act as a deterrent and it will
save lives
as we grip illegal migration we will
create more safe and legal routes
working with the unhcr to identify those
most in need and introducing an annual
quota set by Parliament
we will work closely with local
authorities to determine capacity
Mr Speaker
it isn't true that our capacity is
Limitless
we are already spending Millions on
hotels every day
people do not need to seek Asylum if
they are already in a safe country
it is vital literally vital that we end
the illegal Crossings in the channel
and I commend the statement to the house
shutter Home Secretary of that Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker and I thank the
Home Secretary for advanced sight of her
statement
this is truly tragic deeply distressing
news and all of our thoughts and prayers
will be though with those who have lost
their lives and their families and
friends who have lost loved ones in the
icy waters of the channel
we will think they're thinking too of
those who will be receiving support and
medical assistance who may have been
rescued as well
and all of us will give our thanks to
the brave responders and Rescuers in the
Border force in the rnli and the Coast
Guard in the mod in our emergency
services and in the French authorities
responding not just today to this awful
awful tragedy but also who do such
heroic work every single day it is only
because of their Brave work that more
lives have not been lost
it was barely more than a year ago that
27 lives were lost when a boat went down
and all of us have warned all of us have
feared that it was just a matter of time
before more lives were lost it is of
course why the UK and France both need
to act to stop these dangerous Boat
Crossings
the brutal truth as well is that
criminal gangs have made money from
those lives that were lost today
they have profited as people have
drowned
day after day week after week criminal
gangs are putting lives at risk for
money
and the other brutal truth is that
far from stopping those criminal gangs
those gangs have grown and grown
and the UK and French governments and
authorities have failed to stop the
criminal and Smuggler and trafficking
gangs proliferating around the channel
those gangs have created a multi-million
pound criminal industry with lives at
stake and the action against those gangs
has been too weak there have been barely
any prosecutions or convictions and
barely any inroads Into The Smuggler of
gangs just three convictions for people
smuggling a month at a time when tens of
thousands of lives are being put at risk
each month
this is why we have long called for a
long time for a major boost to the
National Crime agency because we do need
major action and yesterday the Prime
Minister announced an increase for the
National Crime agency I am glad that he
has made some progress on this but can
the Home Secretary clarify what does it
mean in practice how much additional
funding will there be in practice for
the National Crime agency how much and
for specifically for the action on The
Smuggler gangs how many additional
full-time staff will there be and what
is the sense of scale on this because I
fear still that this is too low and this
is too little given the scale of the
problem we Face yesterday the Prime
Minister announced a small boat
operational command again how different
is that to the previous clandestine
Channel threat command led by Commander
Dan Omani which has been in operation
for some time will it still be led by
Commander Dan Omani or by somebody else
will it be the home office or the mod in
charge is it correct that the Navy has
been told they will be standing down on
the 31st of January can she update us
too on the French patrols and
surveillance has the 40 percent promised
increase in patrols started yet and when
will it was this boat picked up as a
result of increased surveillance if it
wasn't what was the reason for that the
Home Secretary has also referred two
safe legal routes she was pressed at the
select committee on a lack of safe legal
routes for children trying to unite with
family in the UK when will she be taking
action to address that to prevent
children seeking to rejoin family in the
UK making desperate Journeys and she
referred to to the prime minister's
statement yesterday can she clarify we
have also called for the fast track for
safe countries and for the backlog to be
cleared the home the Prime Minister said
the set he had set a personal Target of
117 000 cases to be cleared by the end
of next year number 10 later said that
Target was 92 000. could she again
confirm which of those it is
the responsibility for the lives that
have been lost in the channel lies with
the criminal gangs they need to be
caught they need to be prosecuted they
need to be jailed for the loss of life
in the cold sea and we need
comprehensive action we gathered in this
house just over a year ago to lament the
loss of 27 lives none of us want to do
so again none of us want to be here
again that's where we need action before
more lives are lost in Peril on the sea
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker well today is a day
to demonstrate our Sympathy for the
victims and the families of this deadly
and tragic incident it is a day to
Express gratitude to our hard-working
Emergency Services border force and
search and rescue and mod colleagues who
at this moment are conducting an
operation in the channel in very
difficult and challenging circumstances
The Honorable late my Ryan Mulaney
mentions a few points and I want to
respond to some of those in detail
the small boat's operational command is
uh going to be a new operational command
that the Prime Minister announced
yesterday as part of our plan to go
further on the action that we will take
to stop the boats crossing the channel
this means that we are setting up a new
HQ the small boats operation or command
in Border Force to bring our Channel and
processing operation under a single home
office command with military support for
specialist planning and operational
advice as part of this we will bring in
new air and Maritime capabilities
including new drones land-based radar
fixed-wing aircraft and more and we will
be more than doubling our current
permanent Staffing levels with a hundred
new staff at HQ and over 600 new
operational staff based at Dover
that's a sign that we are strengthening
our resolve we are strengthening our
will and we are strengthening our
efforts to do whatever it takes as the
Prime Minister has pledged to stop the
boats crossing the channel it will
improve our intelligence and information
sharing with the French it will improve
and build on the cooperation that we
have with Partners in France
the deal that we signed last month with
colleagues in France is a big step
forward in our cross-channel cooperation
for we share a common Challenge and that
new Arrangement has we'll see more
dangerous and unnecessary Crossings
being prevented last year our joint
efforts uh prevented over 23 000
unnecessary Journeys to date this year
that number is 31 000.
that in itself is insufficient but it's
a step in the right direction and the
agreement that we have struck afresh
with the French will go further to
enhance our joint working
she mentions safe and legal roots since
2015 we have made it possible for 450
000 people to come here via safe and
legal routes that's a record of which I
am immensely proud those are people who
have come from countries like Ukraine
from Syria from Afghanistan
they're people who have come from all
over the world directly from places of
danger including via the UK resettlement
scheme where people have been selected
by the UN Refugee agencies from
countries including Ethiopia Iraq Sudan
Eritrea Somalia South Sudan and Yemen
and though and so we will extend
safe and legal routes once we have dealt
with the appalling people smuggling
gangs risking people's lives as we have
seen this morning
and lastly
that she talks about our track record on
this issue this government won't stop
until we have seen progress until people
understand that taking this lethal
journey is not safe it is not lawful and
it will not lead them to a better life
in the United Kingdom our capacity that
there are there are millions millions of
people around the world who are fleeing
conflict and poverty and who seek a
better life elsewhere our capacity in
this country is not
are infinite we cannot accept everybody
who wishes to come to this country that
is a reality of the world and it's a
reality of Life the other party would
suggest otherwise I hope that she will
join us in our strengthened resolve to
stop this problem by supporting our
measures and supporting our legislation
next year
thank you Mr Speaker I Echo the
sympathies of the Home Secretary and the
tributes to the Rescue Services and
frankly it is a miracle that no lives
have been lost in British territory
waters before now and that's a tribute
to the professionalism of Border force
of the in Ally and Coast Guard and
others and being no doubt the blood is
on the hands of the criminal gangs
responsible for this uh tragedy of
course the best thing would be for those
boats not to leave the shore in the
first place so can she update the house
about any progress she may be having in
discussions for the French counterparts
which will persuade them either to
intercept the those boats if they get
into the water and bring the passengers
back to French land from where they
started or when they do intercept people
on the beaches about to get into the
boats that they are arrested and
detained rather than set free and
allowed to try again the following night
that is the only thing that is really
going to stop this immediately as we
need it to happen
my right honorable friend is right and
I'm very proud of the new agreement that
we have struck with our French
colleagues in in this regard and already
there has been progress in the last few
weeks there have been initial
deployments of embedded offices under
the deal with the First full deployments
before Christmas The Joint headquarters
function is up and running with regular
operational planning meetings between
the UK and French law enforcement and
intelligence agencies and we are working
together with French Partners to achieve
the Calais group agreements that we
struck last week to deepen our
intelligence cooperation with near
Neighbors
Alison feuless yeah thank you very much
Madam Deputy speaker and I first want to
um thank you Peter tribute to my
honorable friend from Cumberland because
I think car can tell the East who so
eagerly fulfilled this role uh before me
Madam Deputy speaker I my SMP colleague
send our condolences our sincerest
condolences to the families and friends
of those four reported to have died in
the early years of this morning and hope
it will be possible for those rescued to
make a full recovery and we give thanks
to all involved in rescue efforts in
such perishingly cold conditions and
those still out searching in the channel
Madam Deputy speaker we want to end
these Crossings everybody the reality is
well let's bring in our political
correspondent Amanda acass who joins us
now in the studio and we heard that
statement there from the Home Secretary
sutherman uh anything particularly new
uh given that we had this extensive
statement from the Prime Minister
yesterday well I think a lot of what she
said was reiterating that series of
announcements particularly this focus on
this new small boats command uh bringing
um uh Everything Under One Roof really
in the home office with these additional
700 uh people being employed to work on
that she did also say that she'd spoken
to her French counterpart about the
incident confirmed of course is the
tragic news that there are now four
confirmed deaths and and said that
investigation was was going underway and
she would update everyone once they know
more she said that this was a sobering
reminder of the of why this um The
Crossings have to end
um but also try to talk up what the
government particularly the new
Administration under issue sunak have
been doing in terms of this recent deal
with France have been struck in terms of
putting more boots on the ground and
having joint border Force officials
working together French and UK in one
place but also acknowledging that we
need to go a lot further
um I think that then opened the door I
think to Yvette Cooper very much with
her response um in terms of arguing that
it was a not much that was new there
Amanda thanks so much we're going to
take a short break you are watching Sky
News coming up in the next uh the very
latest from both sides of the channel as
four people die and more than 40 are
rescued after a boat carrying migrants
gets into difficulty
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]